there's no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody
what's going on i kind of feel like our
camera moved again
what the [ __ ] probably i did
i don't know i went in here i didn't
touch it
i only just came over here
who knows what's happening that's good
who knows what's happening well i wanted
to get like that uh that thing out of
the uh out of the frame
but yeah so what's up everybody it's
wednesday night
it's our episode 300 show episode
300. yeah sabrina was thank was
congratulating us for that yes thank you
very much and uh
show 300.
and uh jenny's got a good one for us
today about an australian dude
about some australia dude yeah she told
me the name after probably the most
famous australian dude
uh of all time probably i just kind of
feel like well this is one of the topics
i remember like a lot of people
recommended it a long time ago
and i remember putting it in the poll
like a bunch of times probably like last
year sometimes and it never won
but then somebody um
one or two people like just a few weeks
ago recommended it again and i was like
oh yeah we should probably do a show
about that so it won this time so yeah
i'm kind of excited so i didn't know a
huge amount
about ned kelly i think i'd seen like
one of the movies about him of the
[ __ ] ton of movies that have been made
about him um
one of which had mick jagger in it one
of which had heath ledger in it uh yeah
they've made like tons of movies about
this dude and like there's songs about
him there's books about him there's just
i mean it's just a ridiculous i guess
he's supposed to be kind of like a billy
the kid kind of guy sort of and it's
kind of like i feel like he's sort of i
don't know uh you know because i've
never been to australia but i do kind of
feel like there is sort of like
some i don't know if i'd call it
controversy but with a lot of people
seeing him as sort of like a folk hero
uh in the
vein of like robin hood or something
like that and then some people just
saying no he was just like a criminal
you know what i'm saying so there's that
kind of thing as well and i really don't
know at this point
if it's ever going to be sorted out
because it was so long ago this was the
early 1900s
no 1800s 1800s yeah 18. there's a lot of
characters like that
yeah most of your old west characters
are kind of like that yeah they're
criminals
they were really entertaining though
yeah a lot of them
depend on what the situation was some of
them more complicated than others i
think a lot was made out of billy the
kid that really wasn't there but uh
jesse james you know yeah bank robber
but there was more to him too a lot of
people
read a lot into into who he was but
he seems to have been kind of like
confederate special forces he was still
evidently robbing banks
to fund kind of like a resistance
movement against the north
which that that could be plausible he
was in in the war
but nobody really knows i think i think
it's mostly i think it's all legend
at this point well the thing about ned
kelly is that they're pretty sure
like what happened most of the time it's
just that a lot of times
his version of events and the police's
version of events are two different
things yeah and so you're never entirely
sure like what to believe because
you know maybe he was full of [ __ ] but
the police were kind of like not were
sort of like looked down upon in that
time period as well and maybe they were
also making up some [ __ ] sometimes the
cops were also criminals in the 1800s
yeah and i think ned kind of pointed out
something like that which i'll uh get
into in a bit but it's yeah it's a
really different it's a really
interesting uh story yeah because i was
saying that ned kell yeah i don't know
if ned kelly's like the most famous
australian but he's for sure like one of
the most famous australians um and john
smith said ned kelly i remember the
movie in which he's played by mick
jagger with an irish accent yeah well
his uh family were irish so uh that's
why but yeah i think that movie came out
in 1970
wasn't the only movie about him there
was like a [ __ ] done
but i think that was the only one that
i've seen and that was like a long time
ago tyler the guy says i think the most
famous australian is probably steve
irwin oh
thank you zach steve irwin has left the
chat also ned's hood would make a good
halloween costume because that [ __ ] is
nightmare fuel i was thinking that but
when you see his outfit it kind of looks
like from far away i know it's made of
metal and stuff but from far away it
looks like the zodiac so i kind of feel
like if you wore something like that
nowadays people would just say are you
like the robotic zodiac you're like no
i'm ned kelly and everybody be like who
they wouldn't know that like in the
united states but in australia they even
have like big statues of the game do you
know how we have like bob's big boy and
stuff like that they have big huge ned
kelly ones in his homemade
body armor is it just the head or no uh
it's yeah it's head to front and i think
maybe the arms although i think it went
part yeah it was like super super happy
he made it out of like plowed things
like that he stole you know what i mean
like plow bleeds and uh kind of worked
but
we'll get into that
well it was lead projectiles back then
black powder
well some they had some uh smokeless
powder but it's usually black powder
and lead projectiles without any jacket
on them and the velocities were low it's
easy to stop that
you couldn't stop a modern bullet
with that
it's got to be real hard there are some
steels that are very [ __ ] hard hard
enough to do it
or that it has to be soft enough to
absorb it one or two like a kevlar
they're they're coming out with [ __ ]
meta materials that'll probably
work but they'll be expensive and it's
not really none of that sheds really you
know having worn that kind of crap none
of it none of it is
practical for every
every military situation you know
well it's [ __ ] hot the [ __ ] that he
made i mean obviously this was like the
1800s the [ __ ] that he made was very
heavy and also kind of impractical in
the sense that you could still shoot
with it on but it was awkward you know
what i mean
plus um he mostly just had like i said
he had the helmet
and the kind of the front part
and uh he didn't really make anything
for his legs which would end up like
biting him in the ass so yeah danny
rowling says his childhood home is still
preserved yep that's right
uh yeah armor made from metal plows
honestly there was uh thank you again
zack whoa i just googled him his hairdo
is amazing and his beard is glorious
[Laughter]
it's like a smile you can pet
oh my god that's why
the crazy thing there's like a bunch of
pictures of him actually and there was
one picture of him because i watched a
bunch of documentaries about him
yesterday and today
and there's one picture of him where he
was supposed to be 15
and i was like man that's a hard 15. he
looked like he was about
35 in that picture but they said he was
like 15. like i don't know about that
old but he looked like much older than
15.
i'm just saying he didn't he didn't
really look like a kid but yeah it's um
what was it i was going to say something
about uh
his armor
but oh i was watching a documentary
earlier and it kind of showed it's
probably from a few years ago i think
but it was an australian-made
documentary and they
showed kind of all the sites where
should it happen and a lot of the stuff
is still there like that and you know
and obviously it's a big huge tourist
attraction the sites where it happened
it's like not big not big towns or
anything but
uh it's kind of a big tourist traction
you go they just call it kelly country
and you just kind of go and go to all
the sites and they have signs up and
it's like this is where this siege
happened and this is where this that the
other thing happened so it's apparently
like a big tourist straw you know they
have like thousands of people go there
um
camp guy said i want to get a pretty boy
poof poof pompadour like anthony michael
hall and pretty
quick
[Laughter]
wait a minute it was anthony michael
hall and pretty pink
he was in breakfast club
and he was in weird science
no oh no he wasn't pretty in pink wasn't
he i thought he was in weird science too
he wasn't weird science he wasn't all
that he was in and he was in the
breakfast club yeah he wasn't pretty in
pink that's right he was he was the one
that um that wanted that got uh molly
ringwall's panties okay that's right i
haven't seen them somebody started to
get kind of studly
no okay he didn't really get studly
until um edward scissorhands never
scissor hands because i feel like he was
in all the john hughes movies in the 80s
yeah he was you know a skinny geek he
always played a skinny geek
but then everybody was shocked when
edward scissorhands came out
and he was like suddenly all buff and
studly like a jock and everybody's like
holy [ __ ] that's anthony michael hall he
uh filled out didn't he yeah
yeah he's good in the dead zone series
yeah and he would he was in the new uh
the newest halloween movie yeah he was
yeah yeah yeah the dead zone series man
he was um he was a lady killer man
[ __ ] he was studly
that's that's that's kind of like his
some of his best work being on that
series if you ask me because it's so so
much of it that's such a yeah that's a
good show
that's a good show yeah tammy's laughing
it uh and sex a smile you can pet yeah
i've never heard that before but that's
like a really funny i've never seen a
guy
you never saw a picture of him he's you
should oh well you probably can't google
him right yeah well i had to stop
streaming yeah you'd have to stop the
stream yeah he's uh it's quite a beard
he's got like toward the end
i mean
yeah it wasn't pretty in pink oh yeah
that's right it was uh 16 candles that's
right i got this too confused yeah
anthony yeah that's right okay so i was
right the first time anthony michael
hall wasn't in pretty empty yeah he was
in 16 candles he was in 16 candles that
was the that was the one he was in
uh he got thick yeah
um
john cusack was in one of them
uh yeah i think that was 16 candles also
he was in it for like a minute he was
one of the one of the dorky
one of anthony michael hall's like dorky
friends i would imagine what happened is
i can think about it
you got stereotyped from those roles
yeah and he probably [ __ ] got sick of
people treating him like those
characters he was playing he's like [ __ ]
this [ __ ]
he goes on cycle and goes to the gym
because [ __ ] that didn't look natural
to me
he he got big
i mean he's like just like in the back
of the comic books like the 98 pound
weekly when the guys like kicked their
stuff that was joey
i know joe who was at the charles atlas
yeah that was that charles atlas ad he
got sued for that
because it made unrealistic claims yeah
which is funny because i always thought
like ads making unrealistic claims i
mean i thought you could get away with
that until fairly recently uh
he was selling something i forgot what
it was
it was just a training program and i
think some of it involved oh it was all
um um okay
jenny's sending me down to bradford oh
no
[ __ ] um charles atlas
in the ad claimed that he built his body
using this
technique that he had muscle versus
muscle okay
where you [ __ ]
basically what they're talking about he
was to basically what it was is sit-ups
push-ups
pull-ups dips but then like
i forgot what it was trying to do curls
against one arm that really doesn't work
all right but he's claimed that he built
his body that way he didn't he built his
body [ __ ] lifting weights and taking
steroids
you know what i mean
so you
he could sell his training thing he just
the problem was is that he claimed that
he used that training method to build
his body and and they made him take that
yeah that's there's very specific right
claims you make an advertisement like
there's ways around it like there's
weasel words and stuff but you can't and
something i didn't even realize i was
reading an article the other day just
about something else and it kind of
brought this up but
they were saying you know how back in
the old days you always heard like the
old thing it's like oh you know we do
these commercials with um
you know hamburgers or cereal or
whatever and they use
uh things that aren't food like to make
it look better on camera like we use
glue instead of milk like in cereal
commercials and [ __ ] like that
well um for a long time i guess that was
true but recently they're like if you
sell if you're selling food like in an
advertisement it doesn't matter it's
good print advertisement web or anything
that has to be the actual food
there has to be a picture i mean you can
tart it up obviously and photoshop it
and stuff like that but it actually does
have to be the food that you're selling
which i didn't realize i thought you
could just like put whatever [ __ ] on
there as long as it kind of resembled
like what they're selling you but
apparently it does have to be actual
food yeah you know in the case of atlas
i don't think he had to pay anything i
think he just had to change his he went
he got sued and had to change the uh the
claims on the ad because i remember that
ad as a kid yeah i remember saying they
probably just changed the wording on it
and uh
but that was something that happened in
the in the history of bodybuilding
you know they've talked about it
the charles atlas incident yeah
basically
i mean it's kind of the same thing that
you you see it a lot with um
particularly in sort of the wellness
area with like you know the vitamin
supplements and stuff
they can't come out and say hey this
[ __ ] cures cancer because obviously it
doesn't but they can get around things
by saying promotes wellness yeah because
that's vague enough right that you know
you can get away you can't make specific
claims about what it can do unless you
have like the evidence to back it up but
you can make like real vague statements
like that yeah
and you can't say that you [ __ ]
built your [ __ ] body and [ __ ] it's
charles atlas on [ __ ] progressive
resistance and push-ups and [ __ ] when
there's clearly photographs of you in
the gym working out with weights
you know what i mean
yeah you got pictures of them working
out with weights so
there you go so they had to change it
it's just kind of like i kind of feel
like a lot of those weight loss ads are
kind of [ __ ] too because they're
like well especially not you know
they're like hey we lost weight with
this [ __ ]
i think [ __ ] uh penitence [ __ ]
did an episode on this one time where
they have these things we just like oh
it's the ab current roller or whatever
the [ __ ] and then they show these people
like using it
they don't but you notice they never
come out and say that person got those
abs using that they just show that
person using that that's a fitness model
yeah yeah they didn't get the abs like
and [ __ ] using that thing yeah like
shake weight they just yeah they just
paid somebody that already looked like
that yep to hold that to hold that thing
and you're supposed to make the
connection in your mind they're not
allowed to come out and say
this person got that body using the
shape right going like this they have to
be [ __ ]
i saw the [ __ ] shake weight
commercial back when that [ __ ] was on
[ __ ] television you know what i mean
and that [ __ ] gorgeous fitness model
with that [ __ ] weight and i'm and
[ __ ] i knew better i was like no way
and she build that [ __ ] body with
that little [ __ ] 20 shake weight yeah
because that's come out right now and
that's [ __ ] a decade worth of work
she's got on her yeah and she's about
she's jacked she's jacked on winstrol
[ __ ]
well like i said they hire fitness
models to be in there and you're
supposed to make the association right
oh well
she uses that thing and she looks like
that they require you to see that thing
but they can't well they're not allowed
they're not allowed to say that right
because it's not true no they're not
allowed so they can get around it yeah
and you know and if you kind of sue them
or something like they're like hey we
never said that you made that assumption
we never said that outright see that's
how they get around association that's
how they get around it
um yeah somebody was saying that uh
anthony michael hall called out at a
convention
called out uh chevy chase for being late
and i'm like that's pretty funny tyler
the guy said since uh chevy is no chevy
is notorious for being a dick oh he's i
believe yeah i've heard everybody sees i
have never heard a single person say
that he was not just a complete flaming
[ __ ] yeah which is
and then which is quite an achievement
and he's not funny
yeah he's not funny at all that's all
his writers and [ __ ]
he just have a funny bone in his body
that's so weird to me
because like some of these like national
lampoon's vacation and stuff like that
he's like pretty funny in those
but
apparently like as a person no they say
he's not [ __ ] funny he's like really
not funny and he's just like a real
howard stern had a lot of recorders
where he called he called him and
started [ __ ] trolling him over the
phone chevy chase over the phone and he
played that on the show every now and
then and [ __ ] dude had no sense of
humor
none
and evidently everybody that's ever
[ __ ] dealt with him tried to joke
around with him he's just like a dick
total dick
no sense of humor i wonder how uh how a
comedian gets to be like that
somebody can
you know a write foreign
a lot of people don't you you know
[ __ ] get their feelings hurt when i
say your favorite rock star or [ __ ] a
lot of times or your favorite pop star
your favorite comedian buys a lot of
that material they buy a lot of it
billy idol
bought most of those songs but so did
elvis
you know but you know at least he kind
of fesses up to that
some of it he wrote but then he bought
some of it
yeah and i mean the thing about it is
that if you just have the persona and
you have a good voice and stuff like
that yeah i think most people are kind
of like oh we prefer if they like write
their own material and stuff but
i don't know i'm not really that worried
about it yeah as long as as long as you
are not pretending that you're like the
[ __ ] when you did yeah that simply read
song don't you forget about me was
originally not simply right it's not
who's that uh simple minds simple
simple minds uh don't you forget about
me was originally [ __ ] written for
billy idol
and he was gonna do it but then he
thought it was too soft he turned it
down he should have [ __ ] bought it
then later he came back and
did it as a cover like decades later
he's gotta
and when you hear billy i don't do do
that song yeah it makes a lot more sense
with him singing it
but it was written for him but he
thought it was too soft
tyler said uh chevy chase had a
short-lived talk show oh i remember that
everybody [ __ ] on that talk show too
even and that was a long time ago like
even when that was out said he had all
the charm and charisma of a dead
goldfish
[Laughter]
yeah i think it only lasted like a few
episodes and everyone said it was so
terrible that it just got immediately
canceled he was the glenn danzig of
humor
[Laughter]
like i said i've seen some movies that
he's in where he's funny and like that
he can you know deliver kind of like he
had good comedic timing oh man flash but
yeah and like i said the national
lampoon movies and stuff like that that
he was in those are funny but um i don't
know just i guess personally i don't i
don't know if he really did
did he ever really do stand-up i kind of
feel like he was more like started out
of sketch comedy i don't know don't know
and i don't know if he can see the
movies
yeah and then i know he likes partly
into movies but i don't know if he ever
did stand-up comedy i mean i know most
comedians
you kind of have to like go through the
[ __ ] run the gauntlet of doing
stand-up comedy
but i think one of the [ __ ] funniest
[ __ ]
comedians of all times you know outside
of [ __ ] my boy [ __ ]
looking i should have been drawing a
black anyway [ __ ] what i like [ __ ]
there's a a
jewish american
[ __ ] comic named jackie mason that
[ __ ] is so funny remember him
yeah i remember jackie mason was [ __ ]
funny
and uh you can see his stuff on on
youtube
yeah he did free stuff he's just [ __ ]
hilarious he just
troll he would troll himself just real
just hilarious you know
call the women in the audiences hookers
inadvertently you know
it's a compliment they call you a hooker
nobody says you look like a housewife
you look at a housewife you gotta have a
certain talent to be a hooker and he
goes it's in that right man [ __ ] just
doing [ __ ] like that
ken knack says uh yay hopefully you guys
will be on for a bit longer just saw you
we're live yeah we've only been on for
like 25 minutes and we haven't even got
to the top again
so we're still in the world so you're
good we're still in the warm-up phase
rebecca 10 says ned kelly really yeah i
mean yeah rebecca you're australian
aren't you yeah we're talking about ned
kelly
uh
and then we have ned kelly as a legend
him and martin heymeyer
yeah see there you go
what'd you do cable fell out oh okay
yeah everybody okay everybody's showing
up now everybody's showing up now we
were talking about what a what a
[ __ ] chevy chase was yeah
i don't remember how we got on that top
howard stern
proved it to me that he was a dick he
played all the [ __ ] phone calls he
made to him
but howard stern's a dick too though
over time every time he became dick his
show isn't funny anymore
kind of a
just from another era you know funny how
relevancy moves around
well yeah
the old world's falling
away yeah so it always happens it always
does yeah that's what i mean yeah
vaudeville's long enough that's the only
constant in the world yeah the constant
so don't worry about the concept of the
world is that the old world falls away
it's all replaced by new [ __ ] yeah
that's okay
that's supposed to it's supposed to
because some [ __ ] just gets too old it
just can't be around anymore
[Laughter]
like me
i'm getting too old and i can't be
around anymore what's the flavor of that
drink
uh
well they're both orange juice mine has
vodka in it
and yours is probably tequila orange
juice and something else do the sunrise
tequila sunrise yeah mine's a
screwdriver
dj maniac says i liked fletch and
nothing but trouble which i still need
to send um
yeah i remember seeing that and being
like what the [ __ ] did i just watch but
i haven't seen it in a really long time
i think it's one of those infamous
movies from the 80s where everyone was
like what the like nobody knew what to
make of it but maybe it aged well i'm
not real sure
all right so um what else do we have to
discuss before we get into the into the
topic anything in particular
oh i meant to mention i was gonna
mention this on one of the movie shows
but i don't think i ever got around to
but somebody sent me a message that
you remember how we did
a show a long time ago about the
unsolved oklahoma girl scout murders
um those three little girls that were
like at the girl scout camp and like
they all got raped and murdered and like
left outside and like they found the
next morning uh they finally did solve
that
um
thank you katie hey from monstercat and
wife it's her 21st birthday happy
birthday happy birthday thanks for the
awesome videos guys we appreciate y'all
oh thank you very much thank you very
much and happy birthday
yeah um yes they did solve that and they
had dna and they figured out that it was
that guy uh gene leroy hart
who was the guy that was
kind of living in the cave like near
there he's the guy that they suspected
the most of the time but they didn't
have enough evidence was he still alive
when they found out uh i don't know
actually
i don't think so i think they did they
somehow got a damn sample but i'd have
to look that up i meant to look it up
and then i forgot but yeah they they did
figure out i mean they were pretty sure
that's who it was they just didn't have
enough um
they didn't have enough evidence but dna
they got him oscar said things started
going downhill on the stern show after i
already called him a pelican i didn't i
didn't i wasn't listening when that
happened well here was that i already
called him a pelican he does look a
pelican a little bit yeah why did he go
downhill after that
he got fired he he fired jackie yeah and
then the show started to suck a little
bit more he started firing people around
him
hmm yeah they were the ones who were
[ __ ] writing a lot of the funny
material
well yeah i kind of feel like that's
what happens too is that sometimes
i don't know it's like writing good
comedy and delivering good comedy aren't
necessarily the same thing sometimes you
get that in the same person where they
write all their own jokes and they're
really good at delivering them but
especially when you have ensemble shows
or sketch comedy or something like that
that's usually like a group effort well
then that show was several hours long
maybe five hours six hours a day and it
was five hours
and it was like every day which holy
[ __ ] that's a lot of fun when you think
about think of the amount of work you
got to do yeah i think it was every day
i think it was i mean you gotta like
after a while that's just gonna start
yeah be like jesus christ it was the
internet of its time in the way people
would call in he'd make phone calls and
you'd listen to him and you knew what
howard was doing that day and what he
was thinking and
porn stars would come in and he'd
[ __ ] talk about them and then [ __ ]
could just he'd have guests come in and
and uh the internet was starting to
emerge and he was [ __ ] pumping
these porn stars [ __ ] web pages and
[ __ ] and their [ __ ] they were on
there all the time and he'd [ __ ] ask
some ridiculous questions and
some of it was videotaped you could see
it on a channel called e
which i don't that's probably not even
around anymore
um but it was kind of like
kind of like our version of the tonight
show but it was during the day so it got
you through work
you know
and like you said now that i'm thinking
about it it's like anybody like that
like howard sterner that had a really
popular
show that they did every single day for
that many hours because what it was like
you said it was like like five hours
four or five hours or something like
that yeah yeah having to do that every
day holy [ __ ] that you one dude can't
handle that
no you need a whole staff you would need
writing and [ __ ] keeping everybody
active and bringing up subjects and
robin would read the news and then
they'd comment on the news that was the
best part of just the news
it was good it was a good show
it's just uh internet slowly replaced it
and
he started to become a dick over time he
started to become just like and he was
putting out books and everything in
movies called himself the king of all
media
he was arrogant it was kind of funny you
know because he's like make fun of
himself at the same time
but uh
what was i going to say he um
oh [ __ ] i forgot i was talking about
i said he put out books and uh the books
were [ __ ] funny too oh and what i was
saying is he became
kind of like some of the other djs
that he was constantly downing he became
kind of like don ivis and he hated don
imus
and he put a couple of them out of
business by just [ __ ] driving them
crazy online and sending his fans to him
sending his fans to his home to their
homes and [ __ ]
over the years it's just you know
he's kind of like rage mob and it was it
was almost like that was almost like
twitter of the day it was weird
but it didn't last long i guess you know
decade or so 15 years
yeah i don't remember like the last i
kind of remember like the big
i know he's been around like a long time
since yeah but i remember kind of like
listen to him some in the 90s but that
was the last time i realized yeah days
was the 90s
and i think i read didn't he write a
book called private parts i think yeah
yeah yeah it was a good book i think i
read that i think funny [ __ ] book
funny book yeah i wrote review the movie
was good too
i might have seen the movie i don't know
movie was [ __ ] hilarious it was about
his life and [ __ ]
yeah i think i did see that how he
became a but it was a long time ago how
he got into radio and his dad and [ __ ]
yeah i mean yeah i mean and the thing
about it is like doing this show
particularly now that we do like a lot
of live streams every day and stuff like
that is i can kind of appreciate people
that have these big long
shows that they do every day like back
in the old days we had radio and how you
would need
a whole stack like you had a whole staff
because no to this but it's just me i
mean just you know and so all the movie
reviews we do like i gotta watch the
movies or read the books and i gotta
research the [ __ ] and all then research
all the topics and stuff like that and
it takes like a long time like so
you know so i can appreciate that
maybe if you just like show up but even
even if you have somebody else doing all
the work for you or doing all the
research for you you still have to come
on and like be on and be entertaining
for like that period of time with this
show they had to do the news
they had all kinds of [ __ ] they had to
do but it was it there was a formula to
it
but still that was a a lot the
scheduling would have been [ __ ]
massive
yeah and you know he did have a big
staff you know he was in a building in
the studio and
yeah they had lots down in new york i
think it was new york
that's where we lived we were doing it
from yeah so yeah they were making
millions and millions of dollars you
know yeah so do you have the money to
hire people
yeah
that must be that's that's got to be
nice
although
i don't know even if i had the money to
do that like to have somebody like do
research and stuff for me i probably
wouldn't because i would be too afraid
they'd screw it up
[Laughter]
plus i kind of feel better
like doing my own so i kind of know what
i'm gonna talk about yeah roughly you
know what i mean i don't like to just
have somebody hand me some here this is
the topic for today and then i gotta
like [ __ ] read it it's like i like to
kind of familiarize myself with the [ __ ]
so i can kind of go off script if i need
to yeah you know what i mean
when we originally
[ __ ] came up with this show it was
because jenny had [ __ ] lost her job
and we're like man we're gonna come up
with a job for jenny
so this is just something we made up for
jenny
that was kind of like the guest
but i just ended up being on it
you know all the time
you know it's fun yeah it's fun
it's better than working for somebody
else that's true it's a lot better
she was scared at first because she'd
never been independent from a company
and i had been doing that even when i
was even after i left the army for a
while i was a [ __ ] independently
contracted salesman just trying to
survive on my own and you after you
survived for a couple years doing that
you're going oh yeah you know what i
don't really need
bosses or jobs i can you know i can do
this
just give me the product i will sell it
and [ __ ] blah blah blah
and um
being an independent
contractor you get real used to it after
a while but
it is a mental adjustment you really
feel like you're [ __ ]
out on a limb without any [ __ ]
security or
support yeah i mean well you are it's
like you are but you can make it you can
survive anyway it's just not the same
but the thing is is that every one of
those jobs that you had where you had
all that so-called support those
companies closed or they [ __ ] laid
people off or they're not you can't
depend on them either yeah you've been
doing this longer than you were doing
that
yeah i mean this isn't i haven't been
doing this longer than like my longest
job that i had but this was the youngest
job my longest job was four or five
years no my my longest job was
uh
ten years ten years okay something like
that it'll take a long time to reach
that but you know those days are over
you know most
most people can't stay ten years at a
job anymore not not today's job market
yeah that's true you're lucky to get
three years four years
unless you're in something that's like
construction or
you know [ __ ]
something had to do with the
infrastructure
yeah i mean we've talked about this
before it's like the gig economy it's
shitty in a lot of ways but
i mean you have to like hustle you have
to like pretty work pretty much all the
time yeah to make money to survive but
i'm not really sure i'd want to go back
to the other way though
i mean if some people do that's like up
to them because i know that some people
like that better but
i don't know it's it's stressful though
it's still it's stressful because you
never know
i never know like from week to week what
you're gonna make like what i'm gonna
make so i don't really know like if that
when the end of the month comes you know
when the bills are due i'm just kind of
like
man i hope i have enough this month i
don't know you know what i mean just
from i mean it's not just it's not just
this show i have uh i do freelance
graphic design i do have book sales i do
all that kind of stuff so but i never
know like for month to month how much
i'm gonna make which is a little bit it
tends to work
it usually does it usually does
sometimes i'm a little bit short
sometimes i'm all right but yeah and if
it's short it's okay i can cover [ __ ]
yeah you know what i mean so but it's
just it's long you know
because you have most of it
yeah you know someone that it's yeah
it's not like i have nothing yeah like i
gotta [ __ ] throw out a thousand
dollars that month you know what i mean
so it's yeah you've never had it yeah
you've never had a deal it's only like
50 here 100 here and it's not really a
big deal
yeah i mean i don't think i've ever been
more than like maybe 100 or 200 yeah
short yeah it's never it's never even
really put me out or anything yeah
so
it's like
i don't even remember when it happened i
didn't you know i didn't really even
really notice it because we'll spend
that in a [ __ ] club we'll spend a
hundred bucks in a club
well we did last week
[Laughter]
i think that was hundred and three
dollars yeah 103.99 well for both that's
for both of us not counting gas
oh yeah that's right and we got that
yeah we had to buy gas too yeah so that
was that but i got to get you some new
clothes too
yeah my clothes are wearing out your
gloves are weird i gotta get you some
new [ __ ] pants and [ __ ] some cool ass
[ __ ] pants
yeah some teddy shirts titties not
enough [ __ ] titties when you go out
[ __ ] you hiding that [ __ ] and cooking
with the [ __ ] now let me tell them we're
gonna get you some [ __ ] i want them
[ __ ] things up around your ears
yeah that'll work that'll be real
that'll be really beautiful for me
comfortable yeah
he just wants to walk in he just wants
to he just wants to meet he shows me to
be uncomfortable showing her off all
night walking so i could just stand
there and be like wow i could stand
there she dances all [ __ ] nightmares
yeah well i wouldn't if i was all
uncomfortable i'm just okay
all right
it's gonna be okay
is it it's gonna be okay i'm gonna
reassure her it's almost time for me to
make another drink you're doing okay you
got half of it right yeah i still got
half a mile and then when i come back
we'll start the show okay we'll start at
the top
i think everybody's worked out how many
how many are in there i don't know
i don't know
i can't see it on my thing you have to
see it on your thing because i don't
even have youtube open on here i just
have obs open
yeah just like did anybody i got this
really cool shirt from uh fye the other
day like in the mall i got this one and
i got the cthulhu one that i wore like
the other day it's those um you know the
creature from the black lagoon one that
i have
and what the [ __ ] is this thing called
riot society that's right
and i guess they have all these shirts
that they do like um that are exclusive
to
fye and they have like a whole line of
them
so
i bought a creature from the black
lagoon one in there the other day and
then when i was in there a couple weeks
ago i got the creep show one and the
hellraiser one which is like the
long-sleeved ones and then we were in
there the other day before we went and
saw fire starter
um
they had
the cthulu shirt which i wanted before
but they only had extra extra large i
was like no i need a small because i
can't do
i can't do the man shirts in extra extra
large it's just too baggy if if they
only have
man cuts
of the shirt then i need a small because
otherwise it just looks like really
baggy
so the shirt what's here
well this one and the cthulhu one oh
okay so uh so yeah so finally they had
the cook they got a new shipment of the
cthulhu ones in so i was like they got
the small and they still had the deal on
where if you bought one shirt you got
the second one for half off so i was
like well [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm gonna get this
one too i'm gonna get like this
halloween one it says something at the
bottom i think it says the nightmare
the nightmare isn't over it says at the
bottom oh can't x going whoa the origins
of 13 o'clock hell yeah it's amazing you
know oh yeah you know we've talked about
this so many times but the show's been
going on for a long time i mean we get
new people all the time though and like
sometimes they might not go back and
like watch the old ones the old catalog
for a long time we didn't even have a
video component i think we only started
doing
well [ __ ] we only started doing live
streams
at about episode 200 and then it wasn't
every week i think that was just like a
special thing that we did
and for a long time we didn't even have
a video component like it was a big deal
it used to be we just recorded the audio
and then i did just like a slideshow
which took forever yeah it's so i that
was one of the ways like when we had a
video component even though in some ways
i was kind of like oh i don't know if i
want to do that but in a lot of ways
that freed up a lot of time because i
didn't have to do these really
exhaustive edited slide shows like i did
before
which took hours and hours so that's why
we started expanding out and doing more
shows because i had more time because
probably you know before that we really
only did
we did the episode
and then we did like a movie review i
think that was all we did like every
week and now we have something going up
like every day yeah it grew the show
grew to where we had to get like a week
a lot of that had to do with the fact
that
in the algorithms you got to take up a
bunch of bandwidth to make ad revenue
and if you don't put something up
regularly this
youtube tries to move you down in the
algorithms
our growth has always been steady but i
always [ __ ] suspected that they have
a slightly shadow band or limited that i
think they're preferring other other uh
um
other shows
maybe like corporate type shows i don't
know and you don't even have youtube red
do you
i don't know i wonder if we moved this
to youtube bread because we're paying
monthly what if they would actually move
us up in the algorithms i don't know
because you know this is like a free
youtube channel
well i mean the thing about it is that i
feel like some channels that are bigger
can afford to put up less
because i noticed that like some
channels that i really like that have
more subscribers than us they only put
up one or two videos a week but yeah
they have a lot more subscribers than we
do so they could probably afford to do
that so because they have like a longer
and some of them it's like less than
that like they only put up a couple a
month or something yeah but you have to
be like pretty well known before you can
get away with doing that yeah
okay so that's uh katy perez she sent us
five that that monster cast wife yeah
okay yeah yeah yeah monstercat um i got
him on facebook i've seen i've seen you
all photographs [ __ ] y'all are a cute
couple and she's a young couple 21 and
you're married already [ __ ] man that's
quite a commitment 21 i was [ __ ] in
the army [ __ ]
um
in korea uh in brothels on the i've been
hanging out on the dmz i don't
understand anyway you uh [ __ ] monster
cats got some bad ass dreads though i
like i don't know where he's from
but
he's got you you guys [ __ ] look cool
i'll go back and check i think he might
be southern i'm not sure
i got married when i was 22. yeah that's
right she married she married young yeah
i married too yeah
but you know obviously well i mean i was
married for what 14 years 14 years yeah
14 15 years
before i before i met you all right
straw dog said this howard stern show on
e was the greatest thing back in the 90s
it was it was [ __ ] cool but it was
fun yeah because you could see what they
were talking about on the show earlier
before you can finally see it
um
and then danny rowland goes they says
there was an episode in where howard
stern the howard stern show where yucco
the clown called in from a gas station
with a bullseye signed during the dc
epic sniper rampage oh that'd been
[ __ ] funny as [ __ ]
uh tyler the guy says it wasn't private
party the only movie that he was in i
think so private parts is actually a
really good movie
and the book is good too i remember it
being good yeah and i remember the book
being funny
and oscar's talking about hank the egg
angry drunken dwarf yeah
and then cam guy says i wanted to bleach
my hair when i saw tom in the older
podcast oh really that's [ __ ] cool
i actually bleaching my hair [ __ ]
blonde it it it was damn near white
um actually what what kind of inspired
me to do that that that's that's my rob
halford air haircut
rob halford had that back in the day but
uh [ __ ] that was over 10 years ago i'm
so thin in the front that [ __ ] even
having hair
is a waste of time now i let it grow out
a couple days ago i'm looking at it and
going nah that's looking pretty bad
and uh because of the androgens and all
the [ __ ] that i'm on
it's there's less hair now and uh it's
all salt and pepper now
you know that no i haven't seen it in a
long time you didn't notice it i mean i
imagined it probably mine probably is
too but it's all salt and pepper now i
i've dyed mine black for like years and
years and years so i have no idea what
color it actually there is some stuff
that's out there some some topical
steroids that you can put on there that
evidently will cause hair to regrow and
there's another a couple different
things
and you can get a whole head of hair to
grow back but i don't know if i want to
even [ __ ] bother i think i look
pretty good bald
i mean i look pretty good bob
i mean if you're a dude and you look
good bald then go with being bald it
seems like so much easier i wish i
looked good bald because my hair is a
[ __ ] huge pain in the ass and when i
was young and when i was young in the
service i was damn near bald all the
time anyway
i was just shaved down i mean it's so
low maintenance so yeah yeah that's what
i like about it um you're not as pretty
and [ __ ] i got a whole closet
where there were the wigs if i want hair
i'll just go and [ __ ] i'm wearing
here i'm wearing yours yeah you're
wearing a dancing wig
wig hopefully i don't look like dancing
with it holy [ __ ] that would be bad
yeah i just wanted to i just wanted the
plain black today i actually ordered
another like plain black one that's like
that's cut like this one but not quite
as long
because this one is getting a little
naughty and it's a little long and kind
of like a pain in the ass so i got one
that's like this long yeah you know what
i mean i just didn't want to be bald and
fat
is like that's bad but you get bald and
jacked no that's fine you can you can go
with that all the [ __ ]
jason statham and the rock and all those
dudes they're all [ __ ] bald and
they're all [ __ ] jacked
uh it's just you don't want to be
balling fat that's that's the difference
looking like uncle festive you like
uncle fester and [ __ ]
and although uncle faster is kind of
cool looking that was starting to kind
of happen as i was getting older i was
going [ __ ] because you just cannot
keep a slender look when you start
approaching your mid-40s
your your your
your hormones just start to change and
you're going to start getting kind of
pot bellied if you if you don't get in
that gym and if you can get in that gym
hard enough
to stop all the [ __ ] effects of aging
you're going to start getting jacked but
you're not going to feel good because
your testosterone levels are too young
too too low so you have to get on hrt
once you're on our hrt though now you're
immune to steroids you might as well
just take some steroids every now and
then too and get a nice [ __ ]
refresh you know just keep refreshing
that [ __ ]
everybody else is doing it all them
people you see on those mcu marvel
universe [ __ ] they're all on they're all
on [ __ ]
and the girls too
what are you doing pogba she goes in the
[ __ ]
open the [ __ ]
she opened the [ __ ] cabinet
underneath the sink and went underneath
the center she's going and what are you
doing in there what are you doing in
there poop
no okay come on out
there's nothing in there
all that's in there is my makeup mirror
and my coffee stuff she thinks it goes
to another house
or she thinks it goes outside i'm not
sure what she thinks you're so cutie
come on she looks right she's
she goes in there a minute and then
comes out going oh that was boring
yeah she's coming on john the stutter
yeah all those old characters man they
were [ __ ] great man
i would love to have the budget where we
could build something like that here but
we'd have to get a whole another studio
or we could have a cast and but that
will never happen again that'll never
happen again those those morning [ __ ]
zoo shows that was only for radio
um but if you've been following the show
for a long time like a lot of you guys
said uh have
[ __ ] stern's show was one of the
influences for this show
one of them
i kind of wanted a paranormal
and unsolved
murder unsolved mystery type true crime
version of something like that which i
think maybe we have i don't know
but we wanted one and especially when we
started live streaming we wanted one
that was kind of like a hangout too yeah
like that wasn't overly right because i
feel like there's a lot of channels
online where you can just go and have
somebody like have a voice over like
read the wikipedia entry yeah to you
um you know and get the facts like i
want to get the stuff right like i do
actually want to talk about the topic
yeah and get all the stuff right as far
as i can but i also kind of wanted it to
be like more casual like a more hangout
exactly because jenny and i knew that we
would never really
have the mainstream demographic anyway
so you might as well just kind of target
and market it to people who wanted to
hang out other people at work
who need something to listen to to get
them through the workday it was going to
be that kind of [ __ ]
where
we had a small strong following
of you know a few people that would send
us [ __ ] super chats and [ __ ] be
regulars and [ __ ] make comments you
know what i mean
because when we started we couldn't see
the comments we were on a [ __ ]
podcast
well it was pod bean wasn't it
well that was one of the yeah one of the
ones we were when we first [ __ ]
started
and we had like 50 000 people
downloading
quick but we never had any interaction
and we never got anything out of us
we're like look look we're going to go
to youtube where we can have some
interaction you know and that changed
the nature of the show i think for a
better
a lot better yeah once we got to meet
you guys and that we could [ __ ]
talk through you know at least through
the messages then
and then some of y'all [ __ ] i talked
to him
instant message me and khan [ __ ]
instant
me and khan of otland over in mexico we
we [ __ ] instant message almost every
day and bees nest
you know
over just [ __ ] man didn't to do with
the show just the news or you know drugs
or whatever [ __ ]
what hrt and [ __ ] hormones and you
know that kind of stuff
all right so about time to start
practicing are we ready yeah we're
almost an hour in so i mean oh yeah let
me catch up with the comments sb says
just got here aussie icon episode yeah
yeah like i said this is one that has
been requested multiple times yeah and i
had been wanting to like do a show on it
for a long time because it was something
i didn't i like i knew kind of vaguely
the story but i didn't know a lot about
it so
um so i'm glad we're finally getting
around to it
you know i didn't really think about it
ahead of time because i was like oh we
should have done like some big
spectacular special thing for episode
300 but i was like ah well cess just
showed up what's up sass yeah that's
what i was just saying cutie pie
and uh yeah bruce willis that's right
john bruce willis was in and out of
shape being bald well he lost all his
hair anyway bruce was always cool though
but i mean back in the 90s
i don't know if it got out but bruce was
[ __ ] when he was young he was already
bald this is like after uh [ __ ] to me
and all that kind of [ __ ] and bruce was
friends with all the [ __ ] porn stars
uh
he was banging all the [ __ ] porn
stars
over in la that's who he hung out with a
lot of those guys did
porn star girlfriends
tammy says this is by far my favorite
youtube channel oh thank you thank you i
tell people all the time about my
friends on youtube appreciate it yeah i
mean you know
we can i mean it's a personalized show
yeah you guys come here like every
single and we're on all the [ __ ] time
i would get sick of us if i wasn't us
you know what i'm saying so the fact
that like the same people like show up
all the time and i was like how are they
not sick of us that's pretty awesome but
yeah so yeah not every show is the same
and [ __ ] me and jenny will fight
every now and then
we have bad days and good days but it's
the same with you all too
that was the part of the show yeah i
mean i guess that's the thing we're just
like human we're not like
and this like i said this is not we're
not like put on this is we're just
sitting here like talking like we would
normally talk yeah if the camera wasn't
on yeah
you know it gets wild or it's not like
we normally
come meet us at the club or go come meet
some of our friends and [ __ ] down to the
goth club or if i go to the biker bar
[ __ ] that one too
if i get uh no it's different
if you're in florida you know [ __ ]
i we put out what clubs we go to you can
meet us there we go to mannequins
and i go to the [ __ ] the oasis here
and use this that's the bike apart
but [ __ ] if you drop me a line you
tell us when you're going to be there
[ __ ]
what we're normally there on a friday or
saturday or saturday's usually at the
mannequins and then sometimes we go to
uh then we have we got to check out the
new
independent bar
yeah barbarian barbarellas
we haven't been there yet yeah we
haven't been since they moved because
it's farther yeah dimitri's spins the
goth knight there we do all the jenny
does all the graphic designs i help
promote it and [ __ ]
and uh
man she comes up with some po from the
posters for some of these goth uh nights
you guys would [ __ ] love them man
[ __ ] spooky vampire vampiric looking
women look like something out of the
damn haunted house from disneyland or
something looks [ __ ] great
if you guys [ __ ] where you don't have
any of your stuff back here do you i
don't think i do now yeah we need to
have some stuff [ __ ] i wanted that [ __ ]
and put
framed like that and put inside the
house going down the hallways some of
the stuff that she's done looks [ __ ]
good i still have all of them somewhere
yeah she got she's got the data we just
had to have it printed out
i just made one for mannequins they're
doing june 3rd they're doing witches
ball
and uh then they're doing a fetish party
yeah uh at the end of june she's done so
many black metal album covers for all
these [ __ ] black metal bands so they
haven't done that late recently have you
no not for a while because de monte's
out of that
but then uh did a lot of stuff for um a
starry night a lot of their promotional
materials
you did a couple of their albums i think
yeah the inner jackets and stuff um
you know and she did a bunch of stuff
for um
liquor companies
and if you look at it you know it
doesn't but that's that paid you know a
lot of the liquor company stuff
dj maniac says uh octavio is djing up
here on friday yeah yeah octavia hey hey
say hi to him
in a few months that's my breath my
buddy yeah he's cool you may have to
stop in and see him yeah if you do like
uh tell him hi from us yeah
yeah he goes all over the place yeah
he's a nice dude i like him a lot yeah i
like him
and let's see he had this russian
girlfriend
nah never mind i can talk about this
[Laughter]
mind even no not am i saying about that
yeah you probably wouldn't she was
[ __ ] smoking hot remember the one she
had the implants and all that [ __ ]
ev i vaguely it's not coming to your
mind what happened
it didn't have anything to do with him
now it is just some stuff some sideways
[ __ ] we can't talk about that no i mean
i kind of remember something but i don't
remember like all the details that was a
while back he had this [ __ ] hot
girlfriend he's not going to talk about
it but he's gonna talk about it
on a scale of one to ten she's maybe
like maybe like a nine
[ __ ] fantastic body [ __ ] rock hard
[ __ ] implants and [ __ ] long black
hair she's just this goth [ __ ]
she looked like a [ __ ] god [ __ ]
vampire porn star coin that's what she
looked like yeah that's all i'm gonna
say about it
sesame says i'm jealous of that biker
bar it looks like such a cool place to
chill out and have a few drinks plus the
music is my style of music well that's
because i was playing it i was spinning
yeah
there's a there's a he took over that i
took over the jukebox
um because you can the jukebox is online
you can use it's like an app
and you can [ __ ] control that jukebox
you pay it without out of your [ __ ]
account
um so i was spinning stuff on it and
then taking videos
but um
you go in there man it's like moss
eisley star port [ __ ] you know what i
mean there's [ __ ] cameras everywhere
looking down you know people have been
[ __ ] killed in there you know it's
not
it's wretched
it is a wretched hive of skunk
and evil okay
um
but no i'm i'm i'm almost famous in
there now
he's almost famous almost famous yeah
dj manage says we all had a russian
girlfriend at one point yeah
and seth is a threesome story coming up
the threesome stories there's thought of
those
well about the russian girlfriend oh the
rest is yeah
never mind
number five
i don't have permission to talk about
that one that's what i mean i legit
don't remember exactly what happened you
were at the club i know i was but i know
i was but the thing about it is that
sometimes when i'm there one sometimes
i'm kind of drunk and two
um the music is so loud that i can't
really hear much of anything so i only
hear about like 10 of like people's
conversations
so sometimes people will be like oh my
god
and all i hear is
like i can't really so i'm just kind of
like cool yeah like i can't hear you so
so a lot of times i only have to get
like the details like after the fact
because i'm not entirely sure like she
wasn't really a girlfriend of his she
was a girl that he was hidden at the
time and
that's all i'm gonna say
don't ask him about it all right don't
ask him about it he's you know he's
going to die
you shouldn't have brought it up
if you do bring it up blame it on time
[Laughter]
yeah did they just hand them out to goth
dj's like promo cds yeah
yeah
yeah if you're got these
you're gonna get a russian girlfriend
here you go here russian gothic
girlfriend they just said they'd give
her to you like wrapped in plastic or
whatever
that's pretty funny
all right so imagine if morticia adams
was a porn star and that's what you
would deal with
yeah okay
that's what she was like okay
all right so
we've been going for an hour so okay
let's talk about that got to get to this
case let's talk about the actual actual
topic i have a feeling tom that you
might like this guy
no i'm already [ __ ] already
i'm already warmed up because he's in
good company already i got an idea what
we're dealing with yeah yeah yeah yeah
uh all right so ned kelly now for the
australians here among us this will
probably all be very familiar to you but
i kind of feel like maybe maybe he's not
as well known in other parts of the
world as he is in australia because he's
massively famous there uh so yeah
kind of a folk hero but some people just
kind of think he's a villain so we'll
get into that later
but he's kind of what used to be known
as a bushranger which i guess was
something like what was like an outlaw
but you kind of like
hid out in the bush like evading
the authorities and all that kind of
stuff uh he led a gang called the kelly
gang oh yeah oh [ __ ] hopefully guys that
was just a big thing of thunder
hopefully our connection will hold yeah
oh forgot we got a better connection now
yeah i think we mentioned that we got we
actually got a second
second box uh mode or motor thing yeah
and we're in we're and it's right here
underneath the thing right there so got
one upstairs and one downstairs and
we're hardwired right into it
so
if we lose a connection everything's
fast like i look at my [ __ ] [ __ ] here
because on my wireless and everything is
real fast now there's no lags nothing so
it's great but if we lose connection
it's not us it's this whole area
okay yeah because which i just heard
thunder but it might be all right but
it's you know right it's getting to be
that time of year where it's going to
storm pretty much every day
uh yeah sb says we were taught about ned
kelly in primary school he's iconic yeah
i kind of feel like every australian
knows who he is uh dj maniac says yahoo
sirius played him at some point didn't
he i think that yahoo sirius was in that
movie from the 90s called reckless kelly
which is sort of about ned kelly so yeah
if uh if that's the movie that you're
thinking of
so yeah so he's essentially an outlaw uh
he led a gang called the kelly gang and
also a cop killer so there's that okay
um and again we were talking about
earlier his uh kind of suit that he made
this bulletproof armor like this
homemade armor uh very very iconic and
there are statues of that like uh you
know in i'm pretty sure i've seen this
yeah i mean there's pictures of it like
there's photographs of him like wearing
the [ __ ] it looks it kind of looks like
a like a dollar general version of like
a suit of arbor it is metal and it has
like it's like a bucket shaped head with
just like a slit so so like
it's my it's just my phone right now
it's calm down okay it's just on vibrate
okay it's you know it sounds like i'm
being attacked by a sex toy
yeah it's a sex toy it's a phone
grandpa it's a phone
[Laughter]
it's just my phone is over there
tomorrow
uh so yeah so
basically
you know even
not even too long after he died he
became like a huge cultural icon and i'm
talking about like [ __ ] even before
the 1940s i think there were like
more than 40 books written about him
there were songs about like ballads and
[ __ ] like that that came out like right
after his death um there have been like
a [ __ ] ton of movies about him
and honestly the first movie that was
made about him which was called the
story of the kelly gang it came out in
1906
and this is supposedly
the world's first dramatic feature
length film was about
ned kelly
allegedly
uh so they also made another one that
was called the glen rowan affair that
was 1951. the one we mentioned earlier
um 1970 that was just called ned kelly
that had mick jagger in it playing him
you had one called the last outlaw that
came out 1980 there was one in 2003 with
heath ledger in it that was just called
ned kelly also and there was one from
2019 called the true story of the kelly
gang and like i said there's one called
reckless kelly which is like a comedy
that was sort of based on him as well so
hugely hugely famous
uh hugely famous dude
and as i mentioned earlier all the sites
associated with significant events in
the
life and times of
ned kelly and the kelly gang uh draw
thousands of thousands of tourists a
year and there's actually if you look if
you search like ned kelly on youtube
there is actually a really good kind of
australian
documentary i don't know what year it
came out it looks like probably a few
years old but it kind of shows a lot of
the sites which i thought was cool like
what they looked like whenever the
whenever the documentary was filled
all right
so let's get into like a little bit of
background of like what was going on
around this time period in this area
so you had
this the port phillip district in new
south wales
now in 1851
uh this district separated from the rest
of new south wales and became the colony
of victoria obviously named after the
british queen
now that same year 1851 was also the
year that gold was discovered in this
area
so in 1851 the population of victoria
was 80 000
and 10 years later it had ballooned to
540 000 and this is almost entirely
attributable to the gold rush
now as you might imagine
all of these people coming into
this
new district into victoria
was a big problem because they didn't
have enough law enforcement to kind of
like maintain order
and the few cops that they did have
there
the people that lived there didn't
really much care for them because they
thought that there was a lot of police
corruption and that you know so there
was a lot of bad blood between a lot of
the migrants and the settlers that came
to the area and the small amount of cops
that were there that were supposed to be
enforcing the law
so what the police force in victoria did
then was they started recruiting cops
from the uk
and problem was that most of the cops
that came over to australia
uh were
protestants and a lot of the people that
lived in victoria like a lot of the
immigrants that lived there were irish
and specifically were irish catholic
so
um again there was a lot of conflict
between
i mean that might have been one of the
main things is that like a lot of the
cops being protestant a lot of the
people they were supposedly
you know trying to keep in line were
catholics and they didn't like each
other so uh that was kind of a lot of
there was a lot of uh conflict at that
time
now another thing that was going on too
was that a lot of the irish catholic
that had moved into the area at this
time um were usually poor
and what ended up happening was that
there had been
some people like some i don't know i
think most of them were uh english also
and they had come to australia and kind
of taken sort of like the best parcels
of land now they called these people
squatters so squatters doesn't mean like
in modern parlance where it's just kind
of like hey i'm gonna go in an abandoned
building and live there i'm squatting
when they say squatters
in that context in this context it means
that these were really wealthy people
that usually came from the uk and they
took up like all these really nice like
parcels of land uh
you know the land that was actually like
productive as far as farmland goes and
they as you know and they had a lot of
money and they were working the farms
there
and because these squatters had a bunch
of money
they also could influence uh the local
police and also the local governments
and could kind of um you know make laws
that were more amenable to them
uh as opposed to the poorer
migrant workers many of whom were irish
now there so there was a thing that was
called
the families that were called selectors
these were usually like the british
crown gave these families
tracts of land in australia with the you
know
they're kind of like well we'll give you
this land but you have to like clear all
the trees off it you have to like farm
it and stuff like that
but obviously because all the squatters
had got there first and had taken all
the good [ __ ] and they had the money to
like
keep hold of their [ __ ] when these
families got sent over there and said
hey here's some land for you it was like
really really shitty land and you
couldn't really really grow anything on
it so obviously
you know they
remained poor while these kind of like
rich guy kept like
they were like oh well if you if you got
like uh starved off your land they would
just take that too and just be like oh
we'll just
suck it up into our
the land that we already have so again
so that wasn't just like the religious
like uh you know protestant versus
catholic thing but you also had you know
big like rich versus poor kind of
situation going on as well uh so kind of
wasn't a good situation
so
i kind of feel like the conflicts
between
this wealthy group of squatters and the
poorer
migrant workers who are the the selector
families
um that was kind of like a cause of a
lot of like social problems in australia
going forward for many many years
so into this sort of uh you know thing
that was going on
uh edward kelly who you know was named
called ned
he was born they're not sure if he was
born in december of 1854 or june of 1855
but one of those two things
at a place called and i think it's
pronounced beverage
victoria it looks like beverage and i
have heard it pronounced
but i think it's b i think it's b bridge
well i was watching like because i said
well i want to watch some australian
documentaries so i get like the
pronunciation of these place names right
because i don't want to like [ __ ] it up
but that one was confusing because i saw
one documentary and they kept saying
beverage which is what it looks like but
i think it's actually beaveridge yeah
it's a whole town filled with nothing
but girls schools in it
[Laughter]
they're filming porn there be
yeah that's the point the porn town yes
[Laughter]
tyler the guy says ned kelly is the
original iron man yeah yeah
no i got an idea what's happening
strong 78 said yahoo sirius was an
underrated genius young einstein is a
classic i remember really liking that
movie but i haven't seen it i haven't
seen it in a long time which one young
einstein with yahoo series i don't know
that one you don't remember that movie
they used to show on cable all the time
there's an australian movie okay didn't
see it but yeah
so young frankenstein
that's a completely different movie
completely different that's a [ __ ]
classic man i love you right yeah
masterpiece yeah
yeah we reviewed that not too long ago
actually
so yeah so ned kelly that was about back
when mel gibson you didn't know me
back with mel brooks was on cocaine
yeah he was great when he was on coke
some people are yeah some people it just
turns them into like
[ __ ] but now when brooks was on
cocaine he was [ __ ] his movies were
[ __ ] just like everybody it's just
like everything else some people can
handle the drugs and it makes them
better and some people it just makes
them worse yeah yeah and you never know
which one it's going to be until yeah
until you do it oop more thunder
okay so uh where was i so ned kelly he
was the uh oldest son of a guy named
john red kelly
and his wife ellen now his dad was
actually from temporary ireland
and in 1841
his dad had been sentenced to seven
years for stealing two pigs
and back in the 1840s and yeah in that
time period if you got uh they you know
convicted of like crimes like that
they'd send you off to australia you
know
that's that's where they set their costs
for two bigs two pigs yeah
a little harsh
yeah that's what happened when you don't
have no money yeah
i mean
here
here in the american continent
if you stole a horse it was death
but the situation was very different you
stole a man's horse
out in the west that's the same as
killing him
so they hung you for that
but i think well they did in australia
as well yeah
yeah it wasn't uh they they took it very
seriously they took that [ __ ] very
seriously because you're putting another
person's life at risk
and horses were [ __ ]
important all right
pigs come on
that's not that important i know yeah
maybe years for two pigs yeah seven
years but yeah i thought that too it
sounds oh well just wait seven years is
a long [ __ ] time it is
and he got sent to a totally different
country yeah like he was he was irish
yeah they sent him to australia i would
think two pigs would be 18 months
you know yeah local
you know you're gonna send your way for
that [ __ ] whatever yeah well you know
yeah like i said it's a lot of a lot of
the sentences in this i was just kind of
like seriously but then the weird thing
is like sometimes people would get away
with like doing [ __ ] that you probably
like get electrocuted for nowadays but
then sometimes you do like some little
piddling [ __ ] yeah you're like nope 20
years right you know i'm just kind of
like okay
justice is uh just not not applied like
the same across the board what i did
like about the old ways though is that
because there was no [ __ ]
professional police forces out on the
range
you were on the honor system
if you caught a horse thief it was uh
you were judge jury and executioner i
caught you stealing a horse and i'm
going to hang you i kind of like that
i kind of like that in a way
it worked i mean it worked yeah it did
but then but then on the other hand it's
just kind of like well i just don't like
that dude's face so i'm gonna hang him
and say he did well he didn't have to do
that though they just shot it out if
they didn't like that dude
that's true but uh no if if if you stole
a horse they would hang you and you
didn't have to go to court for it
just over it
we're getting to some horse stealing
yeah it's just range that was range
justice
um but no if you wanted a guy dead you
didn't like him then you didn't bother
with any kind of [ __ ]
accusing anybody of a crime you just
shot it out because there weren't any
witnesses anyway
boy did you hear that yeah damn it's
[ __ ]
iron man's coming
john goris said that was the subplot in
mad max beyond thunderdome the exiled
pig thief yeah pig killer yeah
so i wonder if this is probably what it
was based on maybe now this isn't ned
kelly this is his dad yeah red right
so that's that's how ned kelly ended up
in australia was because his dad got uh
got convicted of stealing pigs and was
sent there because you know that's where
they sent the cops
so he did his seven years
in australia
uh so his sentence was up in 1848 and he
goes to the port phillip district which
like i said was breaking off and became
victoria
and then in 1850 he married um
his wife ellen who was 18 at the time
and she had um
her parents james and mary quinn we kind
of get into that a little bit later and
they ended up having uh five daughters
and three sons
now the dad was kind of like a low-level
criminal i guess i mean the kind of the
whole family ended up being sort of like
low-level criminals kind of
now uh the dad read he actually stole a
calf in 1865
and got sentenced to six months hard
labor for that
and after a while he was just like you
know what i just can't [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] anymore and drank himself to death
so he ended up dying couple days after
christmas 1866
leaving the oldest son ned who was about
11 12 years old at the time so he was
kind of like left to provide for his
family which you know was his widowed
mom and a whole bunch of kids that were
younger than him and they were poor as
[ __ ]
because like i said they were on this
land that wasn't all that productive
now ned had been attending school until
his father died
but after his dad died they're basically
are broke as [ __ ]
so ellen who is his mom she's a widow
now and the kids
they moved to this kind of shack on a 11
mile creek this is halfway between
greeda i think it's greeda it looks like
greta but i think it's pronounced greeda
and glenn rowan this was northern
victoria
now ellen's dad james who i just
mentioned earlier he had 25 000 acres up
there which sounds like a lot but the
land was like kind of shitty but he did
have like some cows and stuff so they
had to kind of go up there and stay with
them
now
james and uh some other boys that had
married into the family
they kind of had um
a horse and cattle thieving
thing going on allegedly that's what the
police in the area suspected that
they kind of had a little bit of an
organized
horse thief thing going on which was
actually among kind of the poor families
of the area was fairly common because
like i said i kind of feel like they saw
it as sort of like a robin hood thing
because there were all these like
wealthy merchants that had all the best
land and they had like way more than
everybody else so sometimes the poor
people on the adjoining land would be
like you know what i'm just gonna pop in
there and like steal a couple horses and
maybe they won't notice that they're
gone you know what i mean so sometimes
they would like steal the horses and
like
give and like sell them back to the
people like is but hey i found your
horse like do you have a reward for it
or something like that or sometimes they
would just sell them and you would keep
them or whatever but so there was kind
of like a lot of that going on like them
stealing horses from like the rich
people
so you know and they're pretty sure that
ellen's uh parents
with their land were doing some [ __ ]
like that
now uh in 1869 when
ned kelly was about 14 years old
he met a guy named harry power which
wasn't his real name his real name was
actually henry johnson
now this guy was also irish
and he was another convict that had been
sent to australia
and harry power had turned to
bushranging which like i said just
basically living out in the bush and
being an outlaw so you're basically
stealing horses and cattle and just
scraping by however you can like as a
criminal essentially
living off the land yeah pretty much
taking other people's [ __ ] yeah i mean
that's that's what they're doing
um
now he had actually escaped from uh a
prison in melbourne and was bush ranging
now when ned kelly met him
uh because the kelly family kind of knew
of him because a lot of these bush
rangers
among the poor
they had a lot of sympathizers because
like i said it was kind of like the poor
against the rich in the area right so
if you were an outlaw as long as you
didn't like steal the poor people [ __ ]
which you couldn't really because they
didn't really have much of anything but
so a lot of times um you know a lot of
the people like the selector families
and stuff like that would sort of like
cover for you you know what i mean or
they would like help you out or give you
a place to stay or something like that
so
they they had like a lot of which you'll
see later like ned kelly that's why he
was able to evade authorities for so
long as well because
you know people that were that did this
kind of thing that were bush rangers and
stuff had like a lot of sympathizers in
the area that would help them out and
like hide them and stuff
so uh so the kelly family was
sympathizers for harry power
so
ned kelly starts hanging out with harry
power and becoming essentially like his
protege protege like he's showing him
how to do like bushranging this is how
you be an outlaw like out in the [ __ ]
out in the wilds of australia
so
what they decided to do the first kind
of thing they decided to do
was there was a kind of a wealthy
merchant named john rowe
and they said okay well we're gonna go
and like steal some horses from his land
and then we're gonna go like rob this i
guess like some shipment of gold was
coming in there and they were going to
do that
but apparently when that this was kind
of like this the first one that ned
kelly was on and he was only 14 years
old so given cut himself black but
so they go to do the thing and like the
john rowling started shooting at them in
which case they had to like run away and
sort of like abandon the plan and then i
guess that ned kelly and um harry power
like kind of got in a fight about it and
like were
you know a little bit at odds for a
little while
now the first time though that ned kelly
got arrested or came to the attention of
law enforcement
was uh in october of 1869 he was 14 or
15 years old
and apparently there was a fight between
oh hey poke
she's like what am i doing on the show
she's wrestling a minute ago you're
wrestling oh look at that cute baby
she's like
harrison
but yeah so ned kelly's 14 or 15 years
old and he gets into a fight
with
a guy
uh who is a chinese pig and foul dealer
whose name was ah fook
now
fuch says that he was just walking by
the kelly house minding his own business
and then ned pops out and says hey [ __ ]
i'm a bushranger he says he didn't say
that exactly but said i'm a bushranger
and then swung a stick at him and then
robbed him of ten shillings that was
fook's story
ned kelly said
no what happened was that foo came up
asked for some water
and then
started abusing quote unquote his sister
annie
um because you know ned had a bunch of
sisters
and then
um so they got a fight like ned jumped
in there to defend his sister
and then folk that's like started
beating ned with a stick and then he
like was defending himself i don't buy
it yeah well that's what so they
this is something that we'll see like a
lot it's like a serial behavior from him
like they're all they're all he's a cry
bully
he's incredible cry bully he does kind
of seem like that he does kind of seem
like i'm not saying that the police
weren't picking on him because i think
they absolutely were
but
he was a little bit like that too i
think he was a little bit of like a
fantasist where he was just kind of like
it wasn't me because he seemed like he
was never to blame for anything he knew
how to lie it was that kind of thing
yeah but um anyway he did have like his
sister testified and a couple other
people testified like on ned kelly's
behalf
so they did end up like dismissing the
charges
so then ned gets back hooks back up with
uh harry power
and
uh in like spring of 1870
and so for the that month they start
doing like all of these armed robberies
right
and so the cops are obviously like
looking for them and they know that
harry potter they know who harry power
is but they know that he has like this
new young kid that's like hanging out
with them like his accomplice so they're
trying to figure out who the [ __ ] that
is
now the press found out who it was and
named him
and so ned got captured by the cops like
a few days after that like after his
name was reported in the papers
so kelly gets
brought gets dragged in on three
separate robbery charges now the first
two charges were dismissed because no
none of the victims could um identify
him like positively they weren't sure it
was him
now
on the third charge though the victims
also
didn't identify him
but what ended up happening was that
there was two superintendents who were
like kind of overseeing the case
and they said they didn't even let the
witnesses allegedly see ned kelly they
just said hey that guy fits the
description uh send him to trial so
there was that so like i said i'm saying
that i'm not saying that ned kelly was
necessarily like a hero because he did
like some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and like
he murdered a bunch of people
but i don't think the cops are blameless
in this either because they were
absolutely corrupt and i think that they
were actually
i think they they kind of finagled
things to their own advantage as well
and like did things to [ __ ] him over so
i think this like everyone's kind of
shitty on on all sides of this situation
so yeah basically they didn't even like
let the witnesses see him they just said
yep he fits the description like we're
going to like send him to trial
so they sent him to melbourne and then
he was in uh a lockup and then he went
to um
to another place like to to go in front
of the court they didn't produce any
evidence though but he was there for a
month because back then
um i guess they could just arrest you
and they could hold you for however long
you know what i mean they didn't have a
thing where because i know like
nowadays you know they can arrest you
but they can only hold you for
however like what is it 48 hours
72 hours i don't remember i don't know
the laws but um something like that but
they can't like just hold you
indefinitely until they figure out you
know what i found out the other day this
apropos of nothing but i was like
watching some
some other like true crime thing
apparently in japan and if anybody knows
like please correct me if i'm wrong but
i think in japan they can arrest you
and hold you
without charge
for
23 days
30 days something like that still that
much i know but i mean still like
without even charging you yeah like they
you know i've seen um
documentaries on western guys that went
to prison in japan and
they say they say the time there is so
[ __ ] easy it's not even funny they
said what's what makes time
doing time difficult in japan is the
boredom
they're into repetition and silence and
you got to be quiet
and they said it'll [ __ ] drive you
crazy but
you know other than that it's not like
[ __ ] being locked up out in [ __ ]
southern california
you know what i mean looking they don't
really have
what me and granters would call real
criminals they don't really have that in
japan
i don't know i was watching a thing the
other day there's there's a channel
called lazy masquerade
and he's a british guy i think but he's
lived in japan for a really long time so
he'll cover like a lot of japanese
cases and they have some [ __ ] up
murders happening over there yeah holy
[ __ ] what i'm talking about is the
toughest thing they have and they don't
have gangs to speak of other than the
yakuza
the yakuzaba to [ __ ] them up those dudes
are nothing okay
uh there would be nothing compared to
the mexican mob or ms-13 they're they're
nowhere near that hard they're soft and
you look at them they're not they don't
even have physical power
so they're not really the kind of guys
that if you got locked up with them that
they'd be a problem if i got locked up
with those dudes they'd be my [ __ ]
i'd [ __ ] no i'd [ __ ] them up no
physical strength
they hire foreigners to be their
torpedoes
they're just they're just not tough
they have a [ __ ] hell of a reputation
but that's that's movies
and i've written i've read whole books
about
the yakuza and [ __ ] what they called
speed tribes which means kind of like uh
japanese subcultures you know
um
and no
the yakuza
nothing nothing compared to what you'd
find here in the united states or mexico
or central america no
soft
all right so where was i okay so he
actually got uh released on that third
charge as well even though it seems like
allegedly that maybe the cops were kind
of trying to railroad him a little bit
but i'm not really sure i'm not saying
he didn't do a lot of the [ __ ] because
he did yeah i'm just saying that you
know the cops were not really um
i i don't know i kind of feel like they
did frame him on a couple of things or
didn't like extend the same right stem
that they would have to other people
maybe but not not saying that he didn't
do a lot of criminal [ __ ] because he did
so then in october of 1870 there's this
guy named jeremiah mccormick
and he actually made an accusation
against a friend of the kelly family
whose name was ben gould of stealing his
horse
and then after that this was like a
weird
this was a weird incident
so then
gould the alleged horse thief wrote like
an
indecent note so i guess so like some
porny [ __ ] to mccormick's wife
he takes the note
and he wraps it around two cow testicles
like cavs testicles
right
and then he wants to and then he gives
it to ned kelly and says hey give this
to mccormick's wife
this is how the story goes this is a
very weird like way to go around things
so
ned kelly's like okay fine and then he
gives it to another
one of his cousins to give to her
mccormick comes up to ned kelly and said
hey what was the deal with like the cavs
balls and the dirty note that
that y'all gave to my wife
ned kelly punched him in the face
and then mccormick fell down
so ned gets arrested
not only for his part in
sending this letter with the cavs
testicles which okay which it went
through like three or four different
hands apparently
um and he also got
uh arrested or charged for punching
mccormick
so he got three months hard labor on
each charge so he actually ended up
serving six months hard labor uh for
that little
that little incident
now
after he was released uh
ned kelly got in trouble again sentenced
to three years imprisonment for
receiving a horse knowing it to have
been stolen although later on he said he
didn't know that it was stolen he had
like a whole story like i said he had a
whole story about kind of everything
which maybe maybe this was the case
because i feel like there was a
situation where somebody had a horse hey
here's a horse and he just like took it
and wrote it and it ended up being
stolen and he said he didn't know but i
don't know so the cops didn't buy it so
he got three years for that
so he got into prison in 1874. uh his
mom had remarried a guy named george
king who was his uh stepfather
now he tried to go straight to his
credit like he started working like he
worked in timber he worked at a sawmill
and like work for a builder and [ __ ]
like that
um
but i guess the allure of crime was just
like too much like he tried he went
straight for like three years like two
or three years
but in 1877 his stepfather george king
had a horse stealing operation
and ned kelly started working on that
so
kelly later said that they had stolen
probably about 280 horses
another warrant for his arrest came down
uh in relation to one particular uh
horse thievery incident which is called
the witty larceny and that was when they
stole 11 horses from this wealthy
merchant named james witte
and so he got an arrest warrant out for
that uh it was him and his younger
brother dan who i believe was only a
teenager at the time
um the stepfather though he [ __ ] he
took off they they never knew what
became of him he was just like yeah i'm
out you sons you just you take the heat
now the next thing that happened one of
the most famous incidents in the ned
kelly saga i guess was the so-called
fitzpatrick incident
so april 15th of
1874 i believe it was
so a police trooper named fitzpatrick
goes to
the home of ellen kelly who is uh you
know who's ned kelly's mom now he was
going there because he'd heard that dan
the younger brother who also had an
arrest warrant out for the horse
thievery was at the house so he was
gonna go and like apprehend him like
arrest him
now
fitzpatrick said that ned kelly shot him
and ned said he wasn't there so there's
two very different uh versions of this
story and nobody knows
exactly what the truth of the matter was
this is fitzpatrick's version
fitzpatrick said
i got to the house uh dan wasn't home
so he said that he just hung out there
for like an hour talking with ellen who
was kelly's mom he said there was a
couple other like three kids there too
because like i said she had younger kids
also
now
he said that he's like i heard somebody
chopping wood outside
so he goes outside to see that that this
was licensed chopping and i was like you
had to be licensed to chop wood i guess
you did
so he goes out there to see if this was
like if this was licensed chopping so he
goes out and the guy that was chopping
was a neighbor of theirs named bricky
williamson
and he said i don't need a license
because this is my land and i'm chopping
wood on my land so what the [ __ ]
so fitzpatrick is outside now while he's
outside he says he sees two guys on
horses
coming toward the kelly homestead
and he said that these two men were dan
kelly who was you know ned's younger
brother who was the guy who had come to
arrest
and
his brother-in-law whose name was bill
skillion
so fitzpatrick goes back to the house
and
says i'm gonna arrest you dan
dan said well can i at least have dinner
before we go fitzpatrick said sure and
he just stood there and like watched the
dude eat
then fitzpatrick said ned kelly comes
busting in the house
and shot at fitzpatrick with his
revolver but he missed the first time
ellen kelly the mom
then hits fitzpatrick over the head with
a fire shovel
which you know uh so there's like a big
struggle ned fired two more shots
and he actually got fitzpatrick in the
wrist
uh and wounded him
during this struggle uh two of the other
guys entered the room they both had
revolvers dan kelly got fitzpatrick's
gun
ned then says to fitzpatrick hey i
wouldn't have shot at you if i'd known
it was you
fitzpatrick fainted which ned kelly
thought was kind of funny and can you
mention on what kind of firearms we're
talking about here no okay
not that i not that i remember
uh so he faints and then when he came
back too
ned says uh you need to take that bullet
out with the knife like out of your own
arm like you just pry that out of there
uh so mrs kelly like they do that and
then like mrs kelly put the dressing on
the wound or whatever well man
maybe it wasn't deep well no it probably
wasn't i just thought that was like
might have been a lead fragment not so
much a bullet but yeah okay
if you ever shoot
cap and ball or black powder
the projectiles were big they were soft
lead a lot you know unless they put a
bunch of animody in it but they were
usually soft lead and uh when they hit
they splattered
you didn't have to hit the target a lot
of times like i remember i'd shoot at
lizards and you could shoot below the
lizard and still get the lizard the lead
splatters would get them
with black powder that's when i was a
kid of course i had a different
childhood than a lot of y'all but
[ __ ]
um
so yeah that's probably what they're
talking about
um
lead splatters and [ __ ] lead
fragments inside somebody
were those old-fashioned 1800s [ __ ]
black powder firearms deadly yes they
were it's just that the method of how it
killed you was very different from a
modern bullet it was a lower velocity
projectile very soft very heavy
um
large caliber
and uh
in some cases the wounds were worse
you know
that's why they were amputating whole
arms and legs in the civil war or in the
war between the states here in the
united states
if you got hit in the arm a lot of times
that arm had to go especially if it hit
bone
but they didn't it wasn't about
penetration
nowadays a lot of that [ __ ] just go
right through you
so that's probably what they're talking
about
okay go ahead
uh yeah so
all right where was that all right so um
so yeah distract you i'm just looking
trying to color the color it [ __ ]
give it some flavor that's probably what
happened okay what
yeah what show it bro
she's talking we yeah
what are you talking about yeah okay pay
attention to me she's trying to get on
the show
yeah so mrs kelly uh dressed the wound
like on his wrist
ned apparently then and like i said this
is still fitzpatrick's version of events
uh the kelly family have a completely
different version of events which i'll
get into in a moment
so ned apparently says uh he came up
with some cover story and he says to
fitzpatrick if you tell the cops this
then you know i'll do something not good
for you or i won't like [ __ ] you up or
whatever uh and his mom says if you tell
anybody what really happened then uh
your life will be no good to you that's
what she said allegedly
uh and then they let fitzpatrick leave
he says he rode about a mile away and
then he turned around and saw two
horsemen following him
but he spurred his horse faster and
actually ended up getting to um getting
to like an inn his wound got rebandaged
and then he went on to
report it to his superiors
so that's what fitzpatrick said happened
now the kelly family version of the
story goes like this
ned kelly says
uh i only just found out about this like
right before my trial because i wasn't
even
there like i wasn't he said i was 200
miles away
um and he said i only heard the [ __ ]
second hand
he says his mom like when fitzpatrick
got there to arrest dan
the mom asked fitzpatrick hey you have a
warrant fitzpatrick said i only have a
telegram
and then his mom says well then dan
doesn't need to go with you
fitzpatrick then apparently pulled out a
revolver and aimed it at the mom
and says i'll blow your brains out if
you interfere
his mom apparently said you'd not be so
handy without pop gun of yours if ned
were here
then dan the younger brother
even though ned apparently wasn't there
says there's ned coming along by the
side of the house like trying to trick
him so then fitzpatrick apparently goes
over to the window
um
like looking for him
and then dan cornered him took the
revolver and released fitzpatrick
unharmed they said the wound on his
wrist he maybe got that from like
tripping and falling over some [ __ ] but
nobody shot him because ned was not
there
interestingly many years later in 1879
ned's sister kate who was only 14 years
old at the time of this incident
she said that that ned kelly was there
but that that he only shot fitzpatrick
after
the cop had like made a sexual advance
toward her she was 14 years old
now ned kelly denies this he's like
that's a silly story that wouldn't have
happened uh he says if if he or any
other policeman this is a quote if he or
any other policeman tried to take
liberties with my sister victoria would
not hold him that's what he said so i
would have like [ __ ] him up i wouldn't
just let him go
um yeah so there's also like a couple
other versions where fitzpatrick was
drunk when he showed up and that he
pulled uh the 14 year old girl onto his
lap like trying to like molest her and
stuff
and uh
then there was like a struggle
fitzpatrick pulled out his gun and then
ned came up and they fought with him and
[ __ ] like that uh but nobody they said
they didn't shoot him fitzpatrick said
ned shot him
ned at first said he wasn't there
but and that he didn't shoot him like if
he had a wind on his wrist investment
for something else now later on though
three police officers gave sworn
evidence that kelly after he was
captured
admitted that he had shot fitzpatrick
although he was trying to paint it more
as though it was like self-defense or
something like that um not just coming
in and shooting them or whatever so
nobody really knows like what really
happened at that because they both have
like wildly different [ __ ] uh wildly
different stories about that wherever
this guy goes there's a wildly different
story that's well yeah
makes me
makes me think that the boy knew how to
spin a narrative
uh i think he definitely did i think he
definitely did um like i said i'm not
wherever i go there isn't a narrative
there isn't three or four other stories
there's one story if there's three or
four different stories wherever a
[ __ ] goes he's a real good
storyteller motherfucker's a liar yes
he's a spirit
fabricator of course his fabric of
course
well he seemed to have
i mean everything was very
self-serving and like i said i'm not
i get where he's coming from like i get
like the whole context of like how he
grew up i get that there was like a lot
of resentment not just him like a lot of
people in the area and there's a reason
why
um he became a folk hero and why he had
so many
people who were in the same situation as
him uh that were willing to hide him
from the police and like [ __ ] like that
yeah so
so i'm not like
i don't know i'm not like excusing [ __ ]
he did because it was like bad but i can
see like where this where uh the folk
hero status comes from let me address
john he said something he said look he
said the yakuza are very [ __ ]
connected with business and politics the
japanese have a different perspective on
organized crime yes i would say so yeah
i'm not disrespecting the yakuza
yakuza
evolved
in their own universe
they are
doing what they do in that place there
what i meant to say
or what i wanted to
what i wanted to make clear was is that
if the yakuza or the yakuza i mean
that's that's the accent if you were to
put them here in the united states and
put them head to head with the mexican
mob they'd be annihilated
okay
they are a japanese phenomenon
uh they they are specialized for that
area mostly what they do is collect
gambling debts on gamblers
gambling is not an issue here in the
united states okay there's not a lot of
money in that
here in the united states everything is
about the drug trade and when you're
involved in the drug trade
man the mexican mob they even displaced
the italian mob
and when you see the videos that friends
of mine in mexico have sent me what they
do to [ __ ] dudes over there like
cutting their faces off alive while
they're pumping adrenaline and blood
into them to keep them as alive as
possible for so they can be awake for
that [ __ ] after they've cut their
tongues out and stuff
i've got it right here in my i'll show
you if you want
i can't watch that kind of [ __ ] yeah man
yakuza could never do that they are
operating inside a civilization
and organized crime always has has to
[ __ ] take place within a civilization
but the mexican mob is
taking place inside of a [ __ ] aztec
style mexican civilization that has a
very bigger threshold you know
they are intimidating one another and
the government
it's just a whole nother [ __ ] game
the yakuza are more like uh
more like a symbiote that has [ __ ]
attached to something it's not so much
of a [ __ ] of a
of a predator you know this it's a very
different situation
to me all that shit's cutting edge
[ __ ]
isometric asymmetric warfare
it's
the intelligence agencies are involved
in it and all kinds of [ __ ] money i
don't want to say anymore go ahead good
good
that's all i'm going to say
why are you afraid you're going to yeah
i don't want to get in trouble
i've been drinking i want to get in
trouble
trouble
just anybody the [ __ ] might
come for me i don't know man freaking
but no i mean i can go to japan and hang
out with the yakuza no no problem i
could go to mexico and hang out with
them
okay wouldn't be a problem
you were to put the mexican mobs ms-13
which is more nicaraguan el salvador
area but they're up here too but
no man [ __ ] south
central american [ __ ]
drug cartels would [ __ ] annihilate
the [ __ ] yakuza
they're just
a lot more vicious
and skilled but when you talk about
brains and brawn mixed together and
training and [ __ ] discipline
i hand that to the to the russian mafia
those guys are great
i mean
they got chemists involved in there they
can make vodka turn blue
and then they would call that
window washer fluid
and send that through customs as washer
fluid and then turn it clear again and
re-label it as vodka
and sell that as vodka without having to
paint well that sounds that crazy i had
i had to do [ __ ] like that when i was a
kid i had a chemistry set that yeah it
wasn't blue it was red you could turn it
from clear to red in the background yeah
yeah
so that's the kind of [ __ ] you're
dealing with with basic chemistry yeah
but the russians have a paramilitary and
a military background and those
[ __ ] have degrees
and um
money and the ability to [ __ ] move
through society undetected
and
yeah the russians are real good real
good
but when it comes to [ __ ] absolute
bloodthirstiness
the mexicans
yeah
all right so after the fitzpatrick
incident where allegedly
a cop was shot in the wrist maybe
uh dan the younger brother he goes into
hiding
uh and ned was kind of like uh not there
as well now interestingly mrs kelly
ellen the mom
and her son-in-law whose name is william
skillion or bill skillion and a neighbor
of theirs william williamson they all
got arrested
and charged with aiding and abetting the
attempted murder of fitzpatrick
now they all got tried and convicted
now the judge sentenced ellen
the mom
to hard labor for three years even
though she had a three day old baby
uh the two men got six years hard labor
now even at the time and even among
people who didn't particularly like the
kellys they were like bro three [ __ ]
years of hard labor
for a woman
who has like literally a newborn baby
yeah that's a little much
and we don't know if she actually yes
according to fitzpatrick she hit him in
the head with a shovel
but
we don't know if that actually happened
or if that was just fits but it just
seems harsh is what i'm saying three
years hard labor
i don't know
so after that um there were rewards
issued for the apprehension of ned and
dan kelly these rewards for were
in back then money a hundred pounds per
head
now i'm not sure if i did
the because i was trying to do like the
money conversions like how much money
would that be nowadays but the problem
about it is that back then obviously
because australia still used pound
sterling
and now they use australian dollars
which are two different currencies so
i'm not really sure what i did
was i put the money
in pound sterling
like what was a hundred pounds pound
sterling like in 1874 or whatever and
what is 100 how much is that now and
then converted that to australian
dollars so i'm not really sure if this
is correct but it's probably in the
ballpark
so the rewards of a hundred pounds back
then per head
a hundred thousand or a hundred pounds
back then would be
about 13 000 british pounds today
which 13 000 british pounds today would
be the equivalent of 23 000 australian
dollars so that was like per so that was
like a phenomenal amount of money i mean
it's a big amount of money now but it
was a phenomenal amount of money back
then
so that was uh that was the reward that
was offered
so the two brothers went into hiding uh
in the wombat ranges which i love that
now
this was where they also had a couple
guys that were helping them out like one
guy was named joe byrne and another guy
named steve hart who were kind of like
part of the kelly gang right
now apparently uh
i'm not sure how true this is but a
couple of the documentaries i saw
pointed out
that after ellen kelly the mom got taken
away
if you remember
she had
um some daughters that were all like
pretty young like so like under like
tween and under
and apparently these girls were just
kind of like left on their own to sort
of like fend uh you know they
and uh they kind of didn't have any food
or anything
they had like you know a house and some
land and stuff but i think they had
maybe one cow and like one horse or
something
and
according this documentary they said
they weren't really sure but they
thought maybe
the cops were thinking oh well maybe ned
and dan will come back like at night to
like help their sisters out
and so they started doing [ __ ] like
poisoning their water like and stuff
like that and so like the horse and the
cow end up dying and all this other kind
of [ __ ] so i don't know if that's true
or not but that was something that i
heard on one of the documentaries but in
any case they took their mom away and
like i said these girls were you know
like teenagers and under there was i
think there was five of them
so yeah that's kind of [ __ ] up
so after that you had a bunch of cops uh
sergeant kennedy and constables
lonnigan scanlon and mcintyre
and they go out in october of that year
trying to find ned and dan
so they camped at this place called
stringy bark creek
now ned
knew they were there i don't know if he
actually saw them like walking around or
if he just like saw tracks and figured
that oh it's cops that are like come
coming here looking for me
but he knew they were there
so the following day kennedy and scanlon
they go out patrolling
and they leave lonigan and mcintyre back
at the camp
now the kelly gang
jumps out at the camp and like surprised
him
bless you i know it's terrible
lonegan pulls his gun out
and ned shot him dead
so that's you know that's one cop
dead mcintyre uh knowing this is not
going to go well he surrendered to them
now kennedy and scanlan who had been on
patrol they came back to the camp
uh apparently ned and the or the kelly
gang asked him to surrender ask them to
surrender and they didn't
so there was a gunfight
now in the ensuing gunfight ned killed
scanlon
and also shot kennedy uh it was a mortal
wound
so he went over there later and said he
just shot him right in the heart to uh
put him out of his misery essentially
now
there was interestingly this one
documentary i saw because i kind of feel
like ned
was sort of trying to paint this as like
self-defense like they pulled guns on me
and it's just like you know i was gonna
kill them or they were gonna kill me or
whatever
um
so
they had a guy who was kennedy's
grandson
and he was a he's a cop too
and he's like look um i don't buy the
whole self-defense thing because for one
thing ned
after my grandfather was dead
he took his
pocket watch
and the pocket watch he's like so that's
pretty [ __ ] up like you don't kill
somebody in self-defense and like steal
[ __ ] off their dead body that's like you
know what i mean
so he's like i kind of think he killed
him in cold blood interestingly that
pocket watch was in the kelly family
because that their descendants or a lot
of their descendants are still alive
um so pocketwatch was in the kelly
family for a long time and many years
later like descendants of the kellys
like gave the pocket watch back to the
kennedy family hey sorry our ancestors
or our descendants shot your shot your
descendant type of thing but they're
like it's yours so he gave it back but i
don't know he said that guy was like
seemed like pretty pissed because like
hey the dude killed my grandpa so i
don't think he's a folk hero you know
what i mean so there was that
so uh so yeah
so now he's uh a cop killer
many times over
so a little while later the victorian
government issues a proclamation of
outlaw re which i love
offered rewards of 500 pounds for each
of the gang alive or dead
500 pounds
uh back then is equivalent to about 65
000 british pounds today
sixty-five thousand british pounds today
is equivalent to 115 000 australian
dollars
also 170
000 for the american something like that
so for each of the gang alive or dead so
that was yeah
so uh basically so the cops started to
go out looking for them but they're not
doing that good of a job of finding them
like i said they did have a lot of
sympathizers so a lot of people were
kind of like helping them out
december 9th of that same year the kelly
gang takes over a sheep station
at a place called faithful's creek about
four miles outside of a place called
euroa now they locked up 22 people in a
storeroom
and had one of the gang uh joe byrne
guarding the captives and then the other
three went into euroa and they held up
the national bank
and they ended up getting away with 2
000 pounds which uh in british pounds
today be 260 000 british pounds or 460
000 australian dollars uh got that in
notes in gold
after that particular crime the reward
for their capture was doubled
so if you caught these [ __ ]
then
yeah you'd be set for life pretty much
now interestingly what the cops did and
this kind of ended up blowing up in
their faces i want to say
january 2nd 1879 the cops used this
thing which was called the felons
apprehensions apprehension act
and what they would do
is they would say well it's also illegal
to
even be
presumed to be a kelly sympathizer like
if you even thought
if you even lived in the same area as
them and were just even suspected of you
know of a whiff of of having helped them
or even like said hello to them or
something like that then they could
absolutely arrest you
and could keep you in custody like
without really charging you for anything
so they decided to use this law like in
the position and i'm not saying that
some of those people hadn't helped him
but they said a lot of people in that
area yeah they probably knew the kelly
family because everybody kind of knew
each other but that didn't mean that
they necessarily like helped them or
were
sympathizers or whatever but the cops
were really like cracking down
and they thought that this would help
him uh catch him
so they put out like all these warrants
for all these neighbors essentially
they arrested 30 guys in the following
days and 23 were kept in custody
uh not really clear if these people had
actually helped or if he they just
happened to be in the wrong place the
wrong time or whatever
um
about a third of them were released
within seven weeks due to lack of
evidence
but they there were nine people that um
kind of had they they had the thing
renewed and they ended up being in
custody for like three months
even though even in their case the cops
didn't have any evidence either that
they had actually helped helped him out
the cops said well the reason that we
can't find any evidence is because these
people are too scared that the kellys
will do something to them like if we if
they
you know rat on them or whatever but
you know i don't know if the police were
just saying that or if the people
actually didn't they're like look we
don't know anything so it might have
been either thing i mean it's kind of
hard to say
now interestingly uh this decision as i
said ended up kind of kind of blowing up
in the cops faces because
it was seen as
essentially like a big [ __ ] uh
[ __ ] on people's like civil rights
it's like look you're
you're sweeping up like all these people
who maybe didn't even have anything to
do with like helping the kelly family
and you're keeping them locked up for
like all this stuff like taking all
their rights away and that's [ __ ] up
so it's like even people that didn't
even like the kelly's particularly were
saying hey that's [ __ ] up
so
it ended up really like switching
sympathies but i think this was like a
big thing that kind of tipped sympathy
more toward the kelly family and toward
the outlaws and kind of away from the
police because the police were using
these really like draconian tactics in
order to like catch this outlaw and
everybody's like hey you know we just
live here on the land and we're just
trying to make a living and you're just
like arresting people willy-nilly and
keeping them in custody for like months
and months when you don't have any
evidence that they did anything and
that's [ __ ] up so it really kind of
blew up in the police officer's faces
uh saturday february 8 1879 the gang
strikes again this time at a place
called jerilderie i think i pronounced
that right uh which is a town about 30
miles north of the murray river
they locked up the two cops in the town
and took over the police station
and stayed there pretty much all weekend
uh and they took their uniforms
and used the uniforms to go and hold up
the bank in the town there too and got
over two thousand pounds at that one as
well in
banknotes and coins
they also rounded up 60 people in the uh
put them all in the hotel like next door
to the bank
now when they held up the bank
ned gives the bank teller
this letter
that's over 8 000 words like it's a
it's a it's it's a lot it's a manifesto
essentially
um now what this ended up being because
there was a copy of this
i'm not sure if it's the same letter
because there's one thing called the
jerilderie letter and there's one thing
called the camera letter i think it
essentially like said the same things
the jerilderie letter it's uh you know
it's online you can read it it's 56
written pages
and it's basically ned kelly he had it
dictated i don't know if he could write
but um he was pretty literate otherwise
but he like dictated it to a friend of
his and the guy like wrote it all down
so this 56 page letter which i read
earlier today
is
essentially every single crime that he
ever committed or was accused of
committed
he had a story for like why it wasn't
entirely his fault you know what i mean
yeah like i know that sounds kind of
glib but that's kind of like and some of
the stuff that he says like i could buy
it like his he
after he kind of started getting famous
i kind of feel like yeah he probably got
blamed for some [ __ ] he didn't do or
there was like misunderstandings and
stuff and he was like pretty bitter
about it which i get
but
yeah so this letter
it was kind of like a manifesto i guess
not like in a unabomber kind of sense
but he was basically just like trying to
justify
his actions and saying like the cops are
always like lying to me and the cops are
corrupt and it's like you know they
blame me for [ __ ] i didn't do and stuff
like that like he would say like i took
some like quotes out of the letter
like one of this is asking for a bicep
shot hold on what's it they're not
[ __ ] that big dude they're not that
big
i'm still in
beginning phases bro give me another
year
go ahead good
oh let me get another get drink
how are you doing you're all right on
that yeah it's okay obviously it's
almost full okay
but yeah some of the quotes that i
picked out like like i said it's a long
letter it was well you know you say 56
pages not 56 typed pages it was 56
written pages so there was only like a
paragraph or two like on each page so
it's not as long as you might be
thinking
you know but
some of the stuff that i wrote down
and i kind of think that some of the
stuff that's in this letter probably
contributed also to his sort of like
robin hood kind of um
kind of persona maybe
especially stuff like this this was
something that was in the letter it says
it will pay government
to give those people who are suffering
innocence justice and liberty
if not i will be compelled to show some
show some colonial strategium which will
open the eyes of not only the victoria
police and inhabitants but also the
whole british army and no doubt they
will acknowledge their hounds were
barking at the wrong stump
and that fits patrick will be the cause
of greater slaughter to the union jack
than st patrick was to the snakes and
toads in ireland
the queen of england was as guilty as
baumgarten and kennedy williamson and
skillion of what they were convicted for
so he's basically
that was kind of another ongoing theme
in this letter and a lot of the stuff
that he said was that well
you know he'd been [ __ ] on his whole
entire life and he was mad because he
saw kind of like cops or you know the
wealthy like uh squatters powerful
people
getting away with [ __ ]
um worse [ __ ] than what he was doing at
least in his mind and he's like oh and i
do this little piddling thing and
suddenly like i'm the worst person ever
but you guys like do worse [ __ ] than me
i kind of feel like that was sort of
like the underlying theme of a lot of
stuff and like i said he wasn't wrong
about some of the [ __ ]
um and he was probably right about a lot
of the police corruption because he
wasn't the only person saying that
but
it is a little bit the the letter is
also a little bit kind of like
justifying everything that he did which
i'm not sure everything that he did was
justifiable but i can understand where
he was coming from
um
and fitzpatrick the guy that you know
there was that whole incident that where
he busted into the house and supposedly
like shot him in the wrist or whatever
he says later on in the letter and this
is a quote i have heard from a trooper
that he never knew fitzpatrick to be one
night sober and that he sold his sister
to a [ __ ] but he looks at you i was
like okay harsh
hold on one second fernando says give us
a bicep shop i look at fernandez's
[ __ ]
his [ __ ] shot that's his [ __ ]
fernandez you got big [ __ ] biceps too
man you must be lifted okay
i'm getting big [ __ ] on here on
the channel asking to see how big okay
go ahead
go ahead i understand
no you're looking good you're looking
good fernandez
you're looking good
friend me on facebook we'll talk we'll
talk about it we'll talk about it
see what program you're on
okay
uh yeah sold a sister to a [ __ ] but
he looks a young strapping rather
genteel more fit to be a starcher to a
laundress than a policeman
again ouch
for to a keen observer he has the wrong
appearance or a manly heart the deceit
and cowardice is too plain to be seen in
the puny cabbage-hearted looking face
now one of the things that he said too
was that i'm
imagining that in this section of the
letter he's talking about
um
the fitzpatrick incident
or maybe something similar it sounds
like that's what he's talking about
because he says
detective ward and constable hayes took
out the revolvers and threatened to
shoot the girls and children
in mrs skillion's absence the greatest
ruffians and murderers no matter how
depraved would not be guilty of such a
cowardly action
and this sort of cruelty and disgraceful
and cowardly conduct to my brothers and
sisters who had no protection
coupled with a conviction of my mother
and those men certainly made my blood
boil as i don't think there's a man born
could have the patience to suffer it as
long as i did or ever allow his blood to
get cold while such insults as these
were unavenged and yet in every paper
that is printed i am called the blackest
and coldest-blooded murderer ever on
record but if i hear any more of it
i will not exactly show them what
cold-blooded murder is but wholesale and
retail slaughter something different in
shooting three troopers in self-defense
that's referring to the um
to the thing that happened at the creek
and robbing a bank i would have been
rather hot-blooded to throw down my
rifle and let them shoot me and my
innocent brother they were not satisfied
with frightening my sisters night and
day and destroying their provisions and
lagging my mother and infant and those
innocent men but should follow me and my
brother into the wilds where he had been
quietly digging neither molesting or
interfering with anyone so he's
basically saying you know we were just
in the woods minding my rm beeswax and
these cops came in here and they
obviously came in here to kill us
so we weren't just gonna lay there and
let them kill us we were gonna like
[ __ ] fight back you know what i mean
so and they're like and these cops came
in our house and like pointed guns at
our mom and our little sisters and [ __ ]
like that and that's [ __ ] up and
so what did you expect us to do pretty
much that's what he's saying
um
yeah so
it's like that kind of stuff where huh
what no no no
it's narrative it is i mean yeah and
like i said i'm not saying that he's
like making [ __ ] up like but he is a
little bit of a fantasist yeah i will
say i will say
psyops psychological operation that's
the joke grant there's hammer said he
talks like willem dafoe in the
lighthouse yet
i gotta see that one again what yeah i
really like that movie look [ __ ] if
you haven't seen the new [ __ ] move if
you haven't seen
um the new viking movie you gotta
[ __ ] see with the northman
william defoe is in it it seemed like
pretty briefly yeah
yeah the same director and everything
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] badass
herman hernandez in there talking about
the mexicans the mexicans are going back
to their aztec roots i saw that [ __ ]
and i was getting ready to go back to my
aztec roots oh it's on my [ __ ] uh
yeah i was like we uh
my viking roots is it's that same
[ __ ] thing yeah i was like oh hell
yeah i got to see that [ __ ] again man
it was a good movie real good that's the
new conan it's kind of like cross
between conan and apocalypto
it's a northern european version of
apocalypto another great movie [ __ ]
gibson did that [ __ ] movie right man
damn
apocalypto yeah yeah
one of the funniest things when you were
talking about him like talking about the
dude in the lighthouse but i this i had
to write this down he called somebody
ned kelly in his letter he called
somebody
he's like uh
it's not too petty also who has no
alternative only to put up with the
brutal and cowardly conduct of a parcel
of big ugly
fat-necked
wombat-headed
big-bellied magpie leg
narrow hip splaw-footed sons of irish
bailiffs or english landlords
okay which i'm like that's that's pretty
creative which is better known as
officers of justice or victorian police
who some call honest gentlemen okay but
i would like to know what business an
honest man would have in the police
as it is an old saying it takes a rogue
to catch a rogue
and a man that knows nothing about
rotary would never enter the force right
so yeah there's that also he said
certainly their wives and children are
to be pitied which kind of made me laugh
too but i was like yeah that whole fat
neck wombat-headed big bill i was like
oh i got to write that down that's
[ __ ] hilarious i'm going to have to
like say that to somebody so if i can
remember all of it
but yeah um
so yeah so that's kind of like a very
famous letter that he gave to the bank
teller and then like later it got
preserved i guess because it was like uh
you know kind of famous
so after this situation uh
the reward for the outlaws was increased
to 000 pounds ahead
and then they brought in aboriginal
trackers uh from queensland to try and
find them
now what ends up happening is that one
guy who was sort of like a sympathizer
it was like a hanger on like with the
kelly gang i guess his name was aaron
sherritt and he was a friend of joe
byrne who was in the kelly gang
now he unbeknownst to the gang
uh at first
became kind of like a
a stoolie he was like an agent for the
police like a like a double agent
now uh when the gang found out about
this
uh in 18 june of 1880
joe byrne
uh
shot the dude dead he's like oh i heard
you were like working for the police
blam so he like [ __ ] killed him in
his [ __ ] doorway
uh so basically what ended up happening
was that
after this
uh there were four constables who were
supposed to be guarding him obviously
they didn't do that good job because he
got [ __ ] killed
they went and hid somewhere joe and dan
kelly who was ned's little brother
they joined ned and steve hart and they
go to glen rowan this is kind of where
their last stand is and like i said
there's kind of like a big um like
tourist attraction there too like you
can see a lot of the sites where this
[ __ ] happened
so they go to glen rowan they take over
this hotel
and they took about 60 hostages
now the hostage you say hostage but
apparently the hostages they all knew
who ned kids were like oh my god your
ned kelly you're famous they're like can
i be your hostage and apparently they're
all just like hung out in the hotel like
drinking and dancing and having a good
time and [ __ ] like he didn't hurt any of
the hostages some of them did get killed
later but like in the fire fight but he
didn't hurt any of them apparently and
some of them were like just were like oh
we're gonna party with ned kelly they
just thought it was like kind of cool
but yeah so they're like all hanging out
in this hotel now what they had found
out was that there was going to be this
train that was coming on uh
from melbourne and i think it had like a
bunch of cops in it they were because
they'd figured out like where they were
so they said okay well what we're gonna
do
uh the train is coming on monday
and we're gonna wreck it
so they
kind of got these two railway workers
and they kind of like bribed them or
something it's like hey can you kind of
like [ __ ] up the rails so that the train
like crashes
and then we can like steal all the [ __ ]
off of the train let's do that
so that's what they were going to do
they kind of had it all set up but what
they didn't know
um
was one of the hostages
was a guy named thomas curno and he was
a like a schoolteacher
and he had been in the hotel for a time
but ned kind of let him and his family
leave
and after
that guy left he went and told um he
went to like where the uh
the train was gonna be and he warned
them hey you know he he was able to get
to them and said hey the tr the track is
[ __ ] up and you need to like stop
so
that kind of plan didn't go anywhere and
the cops kind of like twigged onto what
the [ __ ] was going on and they said okay
well there's gonna be like this big
thing
so at this point ned and the kelly gang
they had made this bulletproof homemade
armor
ned had some and like i think three of
his gang members had it as well they
made it out of like this plow like you
know like some power [ __ ] that they'd
stole like some metal and as i mentioned
it's kind of like it was kind of like a
it looks like a bucket but it kind of
had like the thing it's just sort of
like a suit of armor type of type of
situation like from medieval times and
it had like a um like a bib type thing
that went over the whole chest and back
and it was very very heavy i think it
was like 90 pounds um yeah so it had
like breastplate backplate and like a
whole helmet thing
now
the thing about it though was that
because they'd been hanging out at this
hotel
and because
i guess they weren't entirely expecting
the cops they thought this like train
thing was gonna go so they'd been kind
of drinking some
and so maybe their judgment was a little
impaired um you know what i mean and
when they put the armor on
uh it was a little bit awkward because
it was very heavy and it was kind of
like unwieldy you know like to you know
use guns and stuff like that so it was a
little bit you know awkward to like move
around in uh also might have like made
them feel like
they were
uh you know like they couldn't be shot
you know even though it didn't cover
their arms i don't think and it didn't
cover their legs it just kind of went
over their front i don't even think they
covered their groin area which you'd
think they
i mean i've seen pictures of it it
doesn't look like it did you would think
that'd be the first thing they'd think
of but no
uh so yeah so they knew the cops were
coming so they put their they put all
their [ __ ] on and cop got ready they're
kind of drunk like i said so they put on
[ __ ] armor
and a huge fire fight uh begins
so superintendent hare
uh he gets shot in the arm
and because he saw like ned is like
coming out through and he's like what
the [ __ ] is that like with the armor
because he wasn't expecting like a big
armored dude to come out right
but one of the first things he notices
is like oh well he doesn't have any
armor on his legs so then he started
shooting at his legs which obviously
so uh so he hit ned actually in the foot
in the arm and in one hand now
at this point dan the brother and uh joe
and steve who were the other two guys in
the gang they ran back in the hotel ned
runs out into like the the bush
now the cops keep shooting
joe burn he gets shot in the thigh so he
had
he had uh armor on but obviously the
armor didn't cover his thigh so he got
shot in the thigh like right in the
[ __ ] femoral artery
he was standing at the bar and he uh
bled out
so he died
now about five in the morning ned comes
back with his armor still on
and he comes through the mist like
looking all like a monster and [ __ ]
and again the cops are like hey he's not
armor on his leg so they just start
shooting at his legs
now
most of the people that they had taken
in like the hostages that were in the
hotel most of those people got out um
they either just let them out they
weren't like trapped in there or
anything like that but they let them get
out the last of them came out about 10
in the morning
now
a couple of them did get killed though
in the fire fight there was an old guy
named cherry and he was inside like in a
kitchen and he got shot by the police
like they weren't aiming for him they
were just like shooting in general
and there was a kid named jon jones who
was the son of the hotel keeper
and he got shot in the abdomen and he
actually died later like during the fire
fight
now because ned had been shot in the
legs
uh and he couldn't walk anymore
obviously so the cops actually captured
him uh joe byrne member of his gang
again was was shot in the thigh and he
bled out so he was dead
now dan and steve uh got away
but the cops kept like shooting at into
the area and then set the building on
fire
uh they had a priest after the fire went
out
and uh or actually i think while the
building was still kind of burning
and he went in there and administered
the last rites and said there are three
dead bodies inside
they brought out joe's body who was you
know the gang member
uh and then the other two bodies they
found out later uh were actually the
other two members of the gang who was
dan kelly who was uh ned's brother and
steve hart who was the other member of
the gang so they actually had been
killed they thought they just escaped
but when they went in there they found
their bodies uh what ended up happening
was that they had
knew that they were going to be captured
and didn't want to be taken alive so
they had apparently taken poison
uh so and they were also and then their
bodies are burned up in the fire
now uh so
ned who was the only surviving member of
the gang he was all [ __ ] up though
like his legs were all shut up
so they take him to melbourne and he
gets tried in october of 1880 for the
murder of constable thomas lonegan uh at
the stringy bar the stringy bark
incident
and i think that was the only thing they
charged him with uh out of all the other
because he had shot a couple more cops
too but um they just charged him with
that i guess because they had the most
evidence for that
and uh he got found guilty
and the judge the same judge
incidentally who had sentenced his mom
to three months hard labor even though
she had a three-day old baby
uh sentenced him to death even though
a lot of people in the um
area were kind of like no they were
asking for a reprieve uh but nope judge
was like nope [ __ ] hanging
so uh yeah ned kelly got him i mean he
killed a cop so they they weren't having
it
so they did actually like hang him in
melbourne uh on 11th of november 1880.
yeah and uh apparently his last words
i've heard different ones his last words
were ah well i suppose it has come to
this
yeah well it did i guess so yeah i guess
it did yeah oh well i guess this was
later rendered by a journalist as such
is life
that's the one that i've heard more
often yeah because i think it's kind of
yeah that's what it was though but yeah
i suppose it's come to this because this
is what it is
[Laughter]
oh well what are you gonna do yeah so
the thing about it uh straw dog 78 of
the students they're talking about uh
about this
i guess the aussies love a gallant rogue
yeah i kind of feel and they kind of do
in britain as well i kind of feel like
there's a romantic you know it's a
certain we do it in the in the us too
especially
with old west type figures yeah and a
little bit with maybe like mob type
figures too not as much but i kind of
feel like
if you're not i don't know you can be on
the wrong side of the law
but depending on what kind of [ __ ] you
do
like sometimes people just be like yeah
right he seemed like at least the
difference with the american mob scene
is that those the old
classic gangsters that we talked about
only killed other gangsters
i can't think of any of them that killed
a cop
yeah
it's other gangsters
and they don't kill civilians
you know which yeah and i can see how
i mean i'm not saying it's great i'm not
saying that that's somebody you should
maybe like look up to you but
they're in their own world they're kind
of in their own way yeah yeah it's not
in the same thing as like you know a
[ __ ] serial killer who's just going
around snatching right you know innocent
ass people off the street american
gangsters were in a scene they all knew
that they were gangsters they had [ __ ]
to do they were making a [ __ ] ton of
money they had
good-looking women and
uh esteem in in a way the the
the media kind of knew who they were and
they only killed each other
over [ __ ] that was kind of
understandable a lot of times
to get killed in the mob you had to do
something that was [ __ ] up
so it was so it's kind of a little bit
more understandable why those guys were
um
kind of romanticized remotely
romanticized
they were in the underworld killing each
other and they
those guys were all volunteers
into that world yeah they weren't forced
into that world they were all
volunteering so this is a different game
were they criminals yeah they were
criminals yeah
were they cool yeah they kind of were
cool yeah they were cool well i mean
there have been so many movies made
about it yeah they're cool
uh
would i do it
depends on the money
i'm a little too old for that now but
[ __ ] if i was young and the and the
opportunity was right
yeah you'd do it i think a lot of guys
would
but you're gambling i probably would if
they paid me enough you're gambling with
your life but i gambled with my life in
the us army
you know what i mean i joined during
wartime that first gulf war
and i wanted to go they didn't send me i
went to korea instead
but everything is a gamble
so i understand
why
american italia you know the italian
americans seen why they did what they
did
you know
and even the mexican mob i understand
quite you know what they did why they're
doing certain things
the stakes are higher over there
but uh yeah
yeah okay
that's all i'm going to say about i'm
going to say that but yeah so yeah 78
said i guess the aussies love a gallant
rogue it may have to do with their
overall attitude towards the government
the us and uk have their fair share of
robin hood types and i kind of feel like
i think that that might be the main
reason why it's like nobody's saying oh
yeah it's good to like go around killing
cops but the thing about it is that ned
kelly represented right for a certain
segment of the australian population
then and now
is kind of like
uh a man that was kind of like fighting
the power a little bit yeah yeah uh in
the sense like i found this one quote by
this one writer
who says uh ned kelly is the best known
australian our only folk hero popular
instinct is found in kelly a type of
manliness much to be esteemed to
reiterate courage resolution
independence sympathy with the underdog
so it's kind of like he was basically
yeah he didn't he wasn't a good dude
like he was a criminal
but
he was kind of like fighting against the
institutions that a lot of people back
then like saw as corrupt that were
[ __ ] on the poor yeah so obviously
like a lot of the poor people were
absolutely gonna sympathize
with him he's like yeah stick it to the
man you know what i mean i get it yeah i
get it the american perspective was kind
of like that a little bit different um
the american perspective i would think
would be a lot more like bonnie and
clyde
yeah well bonnie and clyde are kind of
folk heroes
yeah and with bonnie and clyde they
liked cops
uh they didn't want to fight him
if they were attacked by cops they
counter attacked they did kill some of
them
but they also
did what they could not to kill police
there was one guy that they abducted for
a while
and befriended and then let go later
um
it they were mostly against the
institutions of the united states which
were the banks
and the political parties
um but they trained they did a lot of
stuff we got to do a show on bonnie and
clyde
i can't believe we haven't done a show
about it because bonnie clyde hand me a
pen i got there's pen right over there
that's actually a good uh topic i'll put
that in the poll later bonnie and clyde
is more of the american flavor
and they they liked cops they saw cops
as um other working-class people who
were just trying to survive in life they
they didn't have anything against them
um
and they did what they could not to hurt
them
but they eventually got killed by frank
hamer and a bunch of other cops but they
knew they knew that eventually they'd be
killed
um
kind of a cool couple in a way a lot of
stuff that never really came out they
were bisexual both of them
having sex with guys and women
um they were kind of like
proto 1920s
gender fluid that's what you call today
that's the way bonnie clyde were
and the cop that they actually abducted
because
they they kidnapped him instead of
killing him he he uh
gives like testimony and uh
and ended up in one of one of the old
[ __ ] history channel shows
he said that they were cool people that
he liked them
they were they were outlaws
um
he thought that [ __ ] bonnie was quite
cute
and that clyde was uh an intelligent guy
the the difference back then was is that
uh
the united states was very corrupt
all right and uh
the people that were fighting against
the system
that ended up being kind of criminals
were a lot better people than kind of
what you'd find today they were higher
iq
they kind of had
a politic kind of a political slant to
what they were doing
and they knew how to play the old media
of the day
they were good people
i think they were
were they criminals yeah they were
criminals they were definitely criminals
uh they were also murderers
it's just that we
how am i trying how am i gonna explain
this
we don't live in a world of black and
white
it's uh there's a lot of gray
at the time that they were doing this
the government wasn't good either
those weren't the good guys either
well i kind of feel like that's what was
going on in the ned kelly situation too
yeah so i think that's why a lot of
people like why his story like resonated
with him even though he obviously liked
murder people
yeah
it was more like warfare
it was closer to warfare than it was
crime this is his he this was his quote
uh talking about shooting the cops i
could not help shooting them or else let
them shoot me which they would have done
if their bullets had been directed as
they intended yes they said shooting me
so i just shot them back first and so
yeah that's something right
we gotta do it bonnie and clyde yeah i
wrote it down because uh there's there's
uh i think the evidence is better that
was left behind there's a lot of bonding
clad evidence around that is interest
interesting
um they're not like a modern criminal
these are old school criminals
which were uh understandable
more understandable i think in certain
ways
the world was different back then
um
they
they
how do i explain it
i'm trying to get my feelings crossed
the
the 1920s was in the united states was a
very different time
it was a time of gray
not not so much black and white
and they got caught up in that and they
rebelled against it
they killed people but they also paid
with their lives
if you want to go back to [ __ ]
uh
miyamoto musashi
is [ __ ] one of japan's greatest
swordsmanship he will tell you that you
cannot take human life until you're
ready to give your own
and that that's kind of that's kind of
the way they were
it was kind of like a suicide pact what
they were doing
but we'll talk about that on on on that
day
i kind of feel like yeah like you said
these types of criminals like whether
you're in the mob whether you're ned
kelly whether you're somebody like that
i kind of feel like they had a knowledge
that
you know they were going into this they
didn't i don't think they went into it
completely blind they went into it
knowing well i'm probably gonna get
executed or i'm gonna get shot by cops
one day it's almost kind of like suicide
yeah i i kind of feel like a lot of them
did actually
it was like it was like a kamikaze thing
they weren't
arrogant
so arrogant to think that they could get
away with this [ __ ] and live they were
like [ __ ] it
see i think that's what and that's kind
of one thing that maybe makes them more
likeable i guess
than some criminals like serial killers
and [ __ ] like that because right right i
kind of feel like a lot of serial
killers have a thing where they think
they're so much smarter than anybody
else right like oh well they're never
going to catch me because i'm so much
smarter than everybody even though
they're clearly not they didn't have
yeah yeah they didn't they didn't
have that they yeah they didn't have
that arrogance they kind of just were
like accepting
well this is the life i've chosen so
that means i'm probably going to be
gunned down in a hail of bullets one
yeah and they were like my time is
limited i'll be dead in
a few months yeah so uh we're gonna
we're gonna live life we're gonna live
the life that they're denying us
we're to live a life of [ __ ] wealth
and respect
and we're going to live a life of fame
until we die which is soon
you know and yeah they seem pretty they
see they knew about chill about that
right yeah they kind of they kind of
knew the knew the score
cesspi says ned kelly is the most
popular tattoo here every other guy has
one of him really
yeah like i said it's it's kind of like
hard to overstate like how famous like
ned kelly is in australia i mean it's
[ __ ] huge um
yeah grantham said uh
the only cops the mob killed were dirty
cops yeah yeah and strawdrick78 asked
him what's the most realistic cop movie
or tv show granthar says the wire
without a doubt is the most realistic tv
show and the most realistic movie the
one with uh jake gyllenhaal in end of
watch i'm a backup in case people don't
know grampners and i went to high school
together
he is ex-police i'm ex-military
um
yeah and what he said was true the mob
did not want to kill cops the mob liked
cops
they invaded the police
but they had no beef with the police the
police were doing their job and the mob
was doing their job from the point of
view of the mob
the mob were the police for the
criminals
that's what they were mostly doing right
there
the mob's fight was not with the police
the mobs fight with were other criminals
all right and when they got caught they
went down i guess
sometimes they would rat depending on
what it was
most of them said [ __ ] it this these
them
in general
mob enforcers were underworld cops they
were the police for the gangsters
they weren't in direct conflict with
each other
see the godfather one and two and you'll
understand it because there was there
were some cops that played both sides
and paid with their lives
but they knew that they knew the deal
too they knew the deal yeah granthars
also says heat was pretty accurate so
was to live and die in l.a oh yeah i
remember that worst cop movies as far as
accuracy
lethal weapon dirty harry and beverly
hills cops yeah yeah yeah yeah but they
were fun movies i love the other yeah
as far as accuracy yeah accuracy no but
fun yeah i love beverly hills cop
eddie murphy was my one of my favorite
comedian slash actors i love eddie
murphy he's i grew up with him that's
like my big brother i love eddie murphy
grantham also says being a cop is a sad
and lonely and fearful occupation very
few movies capture any of that right
blade runner maybe bad lieutenant is a
cop gone totally off the rails which
granthar has seen a time or two in real
life i've honestly i've been wanting to
uh do a retrospective on bad lieutenant
actually because i saw it come up on
it's on 2b i think and i saw him up the
other day i was like oh i love bad
lieutenant we should totally do a
[ __ ] review on that but i haven't
seen it in a long time i haven't seen a
long time
kevin g says they should make a film
about billy the kid and ned kelly joined
for joining forces i wonder if that
sounds like you know what that sounds
like that sounds like a graphic novel
that yeah that probably should have
happened if it hasn't happened already
billy the kid meets ned kelly because i
kind of feel like somebody please tell
me there has to be like a graphic novel
series about that i know that they made
like well they made a [ __ ] ton of movies
about
ned kelly obviously
and they made a [ __ ] ton of movies about
billy the kid actually there's a new
series that's just called billy the kid
i just saw a a commercial for it when we
were at the theater seeing fire starter
i don't remember what channel it's not
it's a epics or hulu i can't remember
but it's yeah there's a new movie about
that too
uh rebecca said not a kelly fan at all
[Laughter]
yeah i kind of feel like like i said
i know that he's like a big folk hero in
australia but there's a significant
portion of the australians that just
think well he's just like
a murderer and a cop killer and an
outlaw and a
criminal
and maybe he shouldn't be like lauded
and i said you know i kind of agree with
that but i can see where he's coming
from and i can see why
why he became a folk hero yeah i can see
that but it's like i said it's kind of
the same thing as some figures in like
the you know the american west or you
know like mob figures stuff like that
where they did a bunch of horrible [ __ ]
but there's something about them that
like well that captures the public image
at least sure sure
yeah kevin g said one of the earliest
feature films made is about ned kelly
yeah that's i mentioned that like really
early on in the show from 1906. i
believe it is the world's first feature
length uh dramatic film
and it was about ned kelly yeah
um
yeah sesame says billy the kid is loved
but were bonnie and clyde or are they
just notorious
yeah that's kind of hard to say i kind
of feel like
are they folk heroes
well
not to our generation not really
some of the older generations
were they folk heroes no they were more
like freaks
i would say more like freaks
they were um
a mixed bag of
regular people in a weird situation they
were criminals
but they were also understandable
at the time
gotta go back and look at
the body glide stories
it was a weird couple
you had clyde who was
clyde was a bisexual
but he was a gangster
and a [ __ ] thief
and bonnie was
a cute young
waitress that he picked up and they
became kind of like a team
to rob banks
and to evade the police they were what
we what we would call interstate
interstate um
bank robbers
okay
they would go from one state to the next
here in the united states because the
interstate laws back then were very
different
it would rob banks and make money but
they gave a lot of it away
because they didn't own property
you know what are you going to do with
all that money
and then the media got a hold of them
while they were still alive doing all
this stuff
they would
fight
local police and small towns
um
they
they had to um abduct one of them but
they kept him with them for a while they
became friends with him and they let him
go later
it was just a weird situation and
the movies don't really
express the whole story sex was an issue
um
clyde barrow was bisexual he would pick
up other guys and women and they'd have
this threesomes with
and
and you have to look at it from the
point of view of [ __ ] bonnie i mean
she's a waitress and
all of a sudden she's in the
in the in in in in the national [ __ ]
eye you know i
mean in these weird relationships
back in the 20s
having a good time i guess you know i
mean
they didn't live long though they died
and um
part of it was part of [ __ ] clyde's
thing was to take
revenge on the prison system because he
came out of the prison system
the american prison systems where he got
raped in prison
and
they made an attack on a prison from the
outside that he was in
there was a lot a lot of weird [ __ ] in
that story
stuff that is and a lot of it was sexual
which just doesn't really
come across in the movies
which i think is fascinating that's why
i want to do a show on it
you know
they were
strange
the best way
i mean i kind of feel like before
for criminals to become
something like folk heroes yeah
obviously you can't like just murder
innocent people because that's not gonna
but i kind of feel like
uh you know interstate bank robbers yeah
most people can get behind that because
nobody likes banks and they're just like
what they're insured you know as long as
you like you know steal a bunch of [ __ ]
from a bank and like don't hurt anybody
then i think everybody's just going to
be like all right you go yeah
bonnie and clyde were not straight-up
murderers they weren't
uh they were bank robbers and it was
during a time that was uh
uh weird during the united states you
know i mean the banks were being blamed
for all the poverty
uh it was so politics was involved
i think jenny's research could probably
shed more light on it but i just kind of
this is
all based upon things that i've heard
over the years
about those times
and in that particular couple
it was just an interesting couple
yeah and it was kind of a couple where
me and jenny meet him we probably
understand exactly what they were
talking about
uh especially in context of the time
that they lived in
they were interesting and then they died
in a [ __ ]
hail of gunfire from frank hamer and his
boys killed him
and i got respect for frank hamer too he
was a [ __ ] badass lawman but he was
doing what he had to do
there weren't any good guys or bad guys
in this this isn't a black and white
thing this is uh
gray
all of them were gray well like i said i
kind of feel like that's the same thing
with the ned kelly said yeah like i said
i don't think he was a good person
right um but right i think that he in
his mind he had justifiable right reason
for the [ __ ] that he did and i don't
think that like a lot of the cops
pursuing him weren't necessarily good
people either i'm just saying that like
kind of nobody was right people on
either side
yeah i'm gonna say that i'm gonna say
this is that when it came to bonnie and
clyde
i'm not gonna say they were good or bad
they were in combat with the united
states they were like in a state of war
with them
in this and the united states was at a
war with them they were the united
states at war with them
so
i just can't get moralistic behind it
they just had
they had differences that could not be
reconciled
not in those days
what i was saying earlier about like the
bank robberies and how like most people
as long as you don't hurt anybody
everyone's just kind of like yeah okay
steal from the banks yeah i kind of feel
like that's the reason and i've put this
topic in the poll and it never wins but
that's the reason that i always wanted
to do a whole show about the antwerp uh
belgium diamond heist yeah because i
read a couple books about that and that
[ __ ] was fascinating okay it was a whole
gang
of jewel thieves yeah and they spent two
years
like they like had somebody hired in the
[ __ ] like as a security guard they cased
the joint and it was just like the way
because if you don't know like antwerp
belgium in belgium it has like this
diamond district
and around the district they have these
things like underneath the sidewalks
that like after everything closes for
the day it like comes up like these big
poles like made of
concrete and [ __ ] so like you can't get
in there so this gang spent like two
years like figuring out and they got
away with like all this stuff and as far
as i know i don't think any of them got
caught or maybe like only one or two of
them did and they got like a billion
dollars they got like a ridiculous
amount of jewels and like money and
stuff and like i read the book and at
the end i was just kind of like
you go it's good for you you know what i
mean it's just kind of like i know it's
criminal but you know granthar's put he
rude he's granter said uh just want to
put this out there jenny's research is
top notch thank you mad respect from
grantham for the work she puts into
these shows thank you very much i mean
it is it's a little bit harder like this
since we moved the show to wednesday
because i don't have as much time like
to do as much research as maybe i would
like to but i do try to like cram as
much of it as i can like into into a
couple of days you know what i mean and
i try to get and you know and i
apologize if i get some [ __ ] wrong i
really try not to but
you know and i try to kind of give a
balanced view of things but i try to
like at least
read three or four different like uh
you know things of it i try to watch
like
you know at least two or three different
documentaries on the [ __ ] and like take
notes about that so you know
yeah seth says on the run and love dying
together it's romantic in a [ __ ] up
way yeah it is um you know can't deny
that
uh there's this movie wisdom with emilio
estevez
i kind of remember that
was to me more in that too or am i
thinking of something else
wisdom
yeah that was kind of like yeah i
remember that kevin g keeps bringing up
kelly experiment and bulletproof body
armor yeah the uh we talked about that
earlier
yeah he um
i mean it worked but he just didn't have
any armor on his legs though so that's
uh that's kind of what was his downfall
because they were just kind of like hey
no armor on the legs stage but the you
know the upper half works good though so
he he knew what he was doing they all
had it like [ __ ] before and uh as i
mentioned earlier like uh they even have
like um
you know big like statues of him in that
outfit but if somebody wore that outfit
here like if you made that a halloween
costume i think everyone would just
think that you were the zodiac because
the shape of the helmet
looks like
what the zodiac wore
even though that was cloth but it was
like that kind of square
thing with like the eye slit or the eye
holes
i don't know it looked like a cross
between like the zodiac and like a
medieval suit of armor type situation
to me
camp guys serial killers who committed
suicide before police
could question them isaac uh keys yep
herb baumeister
leonard lake yep
maury travis i don't think we've done
we've done a show about the those three
but i don't think we've done one on
maury travis yet i gotta write that down
because i don't think we have
we've done like so much stuff i'm trying
to like find new well
the thing about it is that
we've done like all the main serial
killers but there's still like a fuckton
more out there which is like really
really scary
and there's a couple that i've wanted to
do and we haven't got around to it uh
grant there's oh give me some more
recommendations recommendations of
criminals for future shows
claude dallas coral watts and the days
in killer oh yeah okay i've heard of
that okay i'm gonna write that yeah
claude dallas
yeah because i need some more like true
crime stuff
i mean not that i'm ever going to run
out of serial killers because there's a
zillion
but well the thing about it is that
this is going to be a [ __ ] up thing to
say but
some serial killers like they kill a lot
of people yeah
but
i think it makes a more interesting show
if they kill a lot of people but also
like in a really [ __ ] up
way you know what i mean
because sometimes
i don't know like sometimes you have a
serial killer that kills like 30 40
people but a lot of the you know i know
that's like a [ __ ] up thing to say but
sometimes you want like the show to be
interesting so
i don't want it to just be like a litany
of
you know here's 40 victims that were all
killed in the exactly the same way i
know i know it's a terrible thing to say
but
that's kind of that's kind of like what
i look at when we're doing like a serial
killer
you know
you don't have like somebody like john
wayne gacy that dresses up like clown
and [ __ ] like that
you gotta have like a weird
you gotta have like a weird aspect to it
how long have you been on
two hours and 48 minutes okay
two hours and we're done with the show
right
yeah i got through all my notes actually
which okay so you guys have any
questions go ahead and drop them in the
[ __ ] comment sections that me and jay
will
talk about it if not then we will check
the [ __ ] out here soon grab
what how you doing you want a half a
drink yeah give me another like half a
half okay granster says coral watts
killed between 80 and 100 women in the
70s and 80s but few know about him yeah
it's like i've heard the name but it's
one that doesn't really come up a lot
you know
it's weird because every now and then
like when i'm looking for new topics
like to put into the polls i'm always
kind of like what serial killers haven't
we covered that are like interesting
serial killers so sometimes you have
these like sites will be like here's 10
[ __ ] up serial killers that you never
heard of and then i'll go to the site
and i'm like i've heard of all of these
serial killers like what are you talking
about serial killers i've never heard of
them like i want one that i really never
heard of
so it's getting hard like i said it's
not hard to find serial killers there's
a lot of those there's like a whole
[ __ ] wikipedia page that's just
broken up by country and there's like
zillions but
you know you want one that's gonna make
like an interesting show they have to
have like some weird [ __ ] about them or
something like that like just to make it
a good show
you know
i saw i watched a video on youtube
earlier today which was
i think it was something called serial
killers that
probably don't exist
you know what i mean and that was
actually kind of interesting about
smiley face killers and uh the
manchester pusher which we did shows
about those
which you know nobody's really sure if
those are actually serial killers if
there's a bunch of weird accidents
and uh
he was talking about like a bunch of
other ones too but yeah that was good
um corrupter says also the bath michigan
bombing which killed 100 children 95
years ago yeah i don't remember that
uh the ipsilanti killer the oakland
county child killer uh that was actually
the oakland county child killer i think
i just put that in the poll last week
but it didn't win like the week last
week of the week before
yeah because that's another one
that uh comes up on a lot of lists that
a lot of people don't
hear about
the energy
bombing
ipsilani killer
shark attacks that's a blaire though
dude said
ooh that yeah that'd be good shark
attacks that would be a scary show for
me because yeah i'm really scared of
sharks
because i'm going to put a po i got to
put a poll up tomorrow morning so i need
some like topics
because a lot of times
i don't know it's getting harder to
think of stuff and it's and i know
there's like zillions of topics that we
could talk about it's just that a lot of
times i don't really like think i can't
really think of them because my brain
gets fried after a while you know
sesame says on a side note coral is a
really shitty name no wonder he was
pissed off
[Laughter]
coral core
[ __ ] was putting them glass rods
up [ __ ] dudes dicks and [ __ ]
crunching them with pliers and [ __ ] the
old dean
no he's not talking about he's not
talking about dean coral talking about
dean coral wouldn't have his name yeah
but that was his last name they're
talking about coral watts oh coral what
it was a different guy okay dean coral
that was spelled different oh okay
yeah that was like some
that was [ __ ]
sounding but [ __ ] up okay you know
what's funny i was watching what was i
watching the other day it was one of my
shows i think it was beer and board
games
on youtube
and uh
matt sloan on there like brought up
something about sounding
and nobody else on the show knew what
that was oh no and i'm like oh does that
mean i'm a freak because i know exactly
what that is and i laughed because
nobody else knew what it was jenny nice
[ __ ] song
i saw a video
do you guys know what sounding is
sounding is when somebody takes a damn
rod and puts it down dudes [ __ ]
you're nickel
yeah and they got guys that are into
that
and like sometimes you get larger
because i used to for a brief time i
used i had an amazon store where i sold
like sex toys
and they have sounding kits
with like larger and larger like rods
because you you know you put a small one
down there you put a bigger one bigger
one bigger one yeah there was some porn
man jen came across that would [ __ ]
cause my hair to stand straight up when
i was [ __ ] seeing it
my hair would stir straight up and then
i [ __ ] dive into that [ __ ] i'd be
like yeah i don't know what it is it was
some kind of weird
pain pleasure principles going on and it
was [ __ ]
a german model her name is [ __ ]
penelope black diamond
and she's oh yeah yeah she's this little
skinny german girl a black got a girl
gothic german girl with [ __ ] black
[ __ ] hair for these huge [ __ ]
implants all right this is like the size
of black like like the size of
basketballs
sounding her boyfriend with this [ __ ]
stainless steel rod just going down like
that and [ __ ] he's videotaping it and
my [ __ ] hair is standing i remember
that [ __ ] back on my neck i was like
oh no no no
no
and then there's something about it make
you wanna [ __ ] i can't understand
on the other hand i i really like those
ones where like dudes where dudes have
to like stick their testicles and dick
like through a hole in a box and then a
woman comes along and kills those steps
those never failed to like crack me up
i'm just like looking at you yeah look
at this question look at her squashing
them
that's so [ __ ] funny all you gotta do
is [ __ ] google that
penelope black diamond spell penny lope
penny look black diamond that's how
penelope's with the [ __ ] with the
[ __ ] sounding [ __ ] and it will
[ __ ] you'll understand exactly what
i'm talking about jeffy art says i work
at a fetish shop i was well schooled in
sounding yeah yeah i was just surprised
i said i don't know i guess i just
figured everybody kind of knew what that
was so i was like really surprised when
matt brought it up on beer and board
games and like the other three people in
the show didn't know what that was and
so he had to explain it everybody's
going like oh
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they have the
kit they have like a really nice kit it
comes in like a big black box and
there's like these really pretty like
silver rods and they just like get
bigger and bigger and bigger yeah like
you work your way up well it's just kind
of like when you have a piercing and you
know the gauge and you just like get
bigger and bigger it's like you know
people are into it i guess there's just
something about the [ __ ] pain
principle that [ __ ] i don't know most
people i read i read a book not too long
ago this you might find this
entertaining but i read a book not too
long ago not
not necessarily do a sounding but like
weird sexual [ __ ] where um and if you
guys watch my book reviews you probably
know what book i'm talking about but uh
there was one point in the end where a
dude
inserted his entire head into a woman's
vagina i don't believe it
i don't believe it was a book it was a
fiction yeah you know what i mean yeah
so i don't know well like they did
establish that the woman had like a
really cavernous okay vagina
and he had also like kind of gotten her
up to
it it was an extreme horror yeah he had
like larger and larger dildos for that
purpose because he wanted to put his
entire head in there
okay well we're at
okay we're
[ __ ]
people seem like they're leaving we're
gonna go ahead and [ __ ] go ahead and
shut this down we will be with back with
you guys when now friday friday we'll be
back with your friday friday night on
the side track show and i will make look
i got all that [ __ ] cobbler done down
there oh that's right he made barry
cobbler very cool today and we haven't
had a blackberry cobbler sitting there a
big old sheet pan of it all right we'll
have some of that that sounds really
good sounds good
all right
well thanks you guys for dropping by
this evening and hanging out with us
uh we will see you again on friday
evening for our side track show so
hopefully you drop by and join us on
that
and uh yeah so we'll see you guys then
thanks for dropping by thanks for all
the super chats and good night